Mm Edwards, the ever the contrarian
shows up with an android phone,
drinking tea against the sun.
Second followed. No rules.
Still Mag and pay me sorta.
You had some French fries or dad brought
that were made with clear the legend.
Jamie, you were there. What did you say?
You guys saw French dryer too. Yeah.
Appeared in my life. Listen
to the MGM steakhouse.
Dan Cooking that fucking those French
fries. If anything other than animal fat.
Guaranteed the two delicious. I
didn't see it. I didn't see it.
Even at McDonald's, you
get McDonald's fries.
Apparently they cook them in some
fucking disgusting fat. Well,
that's what makes them taste so good.
What does make McDonald's fries
tastes good? They're pretty good,
but they're not my
favorite. I don't even know.
I get confused when people say they're
better than in and out. Fries. Oh,
I like fries. It tastes like
potatoes either in and now.
Fries are far superior. I don't
like fries. It tastes like potatoes.
[inaudible] don't know fries better than
McDonald's. I do personally feel that.
You know who I hadn't beef with that
about candy Alexander from a news radio.
She was the first person to like, we went
and got in and out like for the holes,
the whole group of us. And um, uh,
she got McDonald's fries.
She went and got McDonald's.
Why'd you get McDonald's fry? She
was like, fuck those bullshit fries,
those in and out fries. I'm like, what?
I didn't understand. They can be okay,
but they're so hit or miss
that they can miss bad. To me,
they're remarkably consistent.
They always taste like,
what are we discussing here? Fries or
mocker. It's like a line. Remember mock.
It's still a common Solak
with five guys fries.
Five guys with the King of fries.
Yes. They have two options.
They have k they're real,
they have the fucking potatoes and bags
sitting in their goddamn store just to
let you know, bitch,
we're using these potatoes and then they
take that bag and shake it in there and
cut it up. Um, they have Cajun fries
so they, when you have another option,
you got spicy fries that are God damn
delicious. I have to stop by there.
Then you don't have to crack
packets to get your ketchup.
They have a giant tub of the ketchup.
He squirt that bitch in a nice
Little Cup, a little paper cup.
You can shower and have that catch up.
McDonald's had that homeless
people would be under it.
Squirt mustard in their mouth.
I'll tell you what man,
since um, Starbucks got in
trouble for being racist. Um,
there's a lot more homeless
people at Starbucks.
Like they understand that they
could just go there. It's really,
it's really odd. That's so funny.
That's true. Get kicked out.
They can get kicked out. He's afraid,
dude. It's a, it's 100% different.
100% different in some spots.
Which ones are you going to
cause the ones in Hollywood,
they know how to handle it for the
most part because they got locks on
everything. I went to a shifty
one in downtown where a,
they didn't even have a bathroom.
Like how do you serve in coffee?
You don't have a bathroom. Coffee
makes you shit and Piss. Yeah,
this is ridiculous.
But I realized they didn't have a
bathroom cause the homeless people,
there was homeless people that had like
this guy had a port and he was charging
all of his devices. He had
everything. He had like a phone,
a fucking iPad and long night ahead of
him to get free electricity there and
they always got like a bag of his stuff.
Like he's got a little camp in the
corner of the Starbucks. I'm like, wow.
On one hand like, hey,
how's the guys supposed to
get some electricity but I
want him to get back up on
his feet. Maybe this is the way to
do it. Maybe it's through that iPad.
[inaudible]. On the other hand I'm
like, Hey, don't get me a disease.
You fucking, I got
Instagram account yesterday,
street people of Los Angeles, which
has got some very interesting content.
Does that a naked person? Yes, it is.
Naked person just changing on
the strange and on the street.
That was actually in San Francisco I
think I remember checking that post but
wow, this has got some interesting stuff.
These guys were like cooking underneath
the tree on a lot with like a live grill
right about somewhere. But there's a,
Tommy's in Hollywood, sorry, go ahead.
Thompson home and uh,
there's always like a bunch of young
homeless people cooking in front of it.
Like there's a bus stop.
They have a lit fire
like caveman, like, like,
like fear of the walking dead style
campfire like outside of the Tommy's on
Hollywood boulevard, like on a daily
basis. How weird. It's just weird that,
that's okay. Like if you just wanted to
start a fire on the side of the road,
would that be okay? No. But can you
start a fire to cook apparently.
Can you or did they just not get
busted? Probably need a permit. Yeah.
Would think you need something like a
to be like a grill street vendor type
permit if you want to sell. What if
you just wanted to give food away?
You can't do that. You can't,
but you can eat it yourself.
Mm.
I don't know. Could you offer it to some,
it seems like you could offer
it to somebody like you know,
if they allow you to cook and you and I
were sitting there and were cooking and
said, would you like some and
you said, hey, that looks good.
That should be okay. It's like a donation.
You know some places they don't charge
you to get in but they accept a donation.
But if you plan in advance you say, hey,
all of us meet on the corner
of third and Santa Monica.
I'm going to have a cookout because,
oh no, no, no, no. House, Sun,
solar. We just setting up right here
on the concrete. Yeah, those do.
People should just go to a
park that has those grills.
Like Griffith Park is not far. Right.
Griffith Park is like people with homes
cooked there. Yeah. You got free grills.
You could just do it up there.
Anybody can cook there. Yeah.
That is one of the nicest
parts of la by the way.
And if people don't know that
is a fucking wildlife area,
that's a legit wildlife area.
There is a real Predator prey fucking law.
The jungle thing going down
right now in Griffith Park,
it's mountain lions and deer.
It is going down and
coyotes day and coyotes,
you are doing all your stuff. It's
a really amazing place, right?
Because here we are. We got past that
Dina and Glendale and Burbank and La,
you know,
beautiful fucking BMWs driving
by these cool people are jogging.
They got earpods in the
jogging and Griffith Park.
The jogging right near a war zone is a
war zone is rustling sometimes go around
the corner and I'm like,
fuck dude, like I'm, I'm on,
I'm stay paying attention a hundred
percent we got a giant framed picture and
headed to the studio of this mountain
lion that was photographed by a camera
trap. You know what a camera trap is?
They set them up to monitor the numbers
of wildlife and to just try to get an
accurate assessment of what's in the
area. So what it is is like a camera.
That's the photo.
It's a camera that operates
on a motion detection.
So as this cat, this probably
hundred and 50 pound,
super muscular grown ass mountain lion
with a fucking collar on his neck.
His name is p 22 that's what it says.
Just say up there just
between 219 pounds as of May.
So it's not quite that big.
So it's still big enough to
kill everyone in this room.
It's in the room with us. We're fucked.
But look how muscular it is. I mean,
that is a look at the size of its goddamn
forearms. Those are Franco Colombo,
forearms.
That is a scattershot animal and that
animal lives around where all these people
are jogging. It's really
strange situation.
I'm never going to Griffith park again.
Fuck would peep till I saw
a p one to five. I'm out.
Stay at my house, Bro. Look at the
Hollywood sign behind it though.
It's so perfect. That's almost like a
fake picture that is so close to me. Yes.
So close to you. I went to the park.
I'm like a block and a half away from
that joint. Do I run with a knife?
Oh yeah, I do.
I run with the this fucking
half face blades knife.
It's called the s h p o
s subhuman piece of shit.
That's what the name of the
knife is. Same, same easy cry.
So they caught him here with look
at that. He's got blood and bones.
He's eating something that
must be like a deer leg.
Fucking a that is madness.
And he's digging a hole in the ground
and stuff it in there to save it.
Fuck man. Because you know what?
The deer around there are
really comfortable. Yeah.
But that could be a kid man.
Right? 100% could be a kid.
But I know why he's there because
the deer in that neighborhood,
like they walk around in the
daytime like their tourist too,
cause there's no hunting around here. So
they're like all comfortable and shit.
I said okay. You'll probably
feed them too. Yeah.
So then now the line that's like, oh,
let me track these motherfuckers over
to this area and I'll just have a feast.
It's a buffet night. Look at
this shit. I'm all in drive.
This is an automobile haul and drive.
There's a grown ass mountain lion with
a collar on that's got a giant deer on
the ground. A buck, not
giant. It's probably a hundred
pound deer on the ground.
Dead on the, on the side, on
the side of the city street.
It's a similar situation.
Yeah. Civilization.
And this is a cat that's killing
deer with its face where we live.
And not only that, we know where
it is, we have a collar on it.
We're playing this game. You don't fuck
with us and we won't fuck with you.
And they won't fuck with
you. For the most part,
the problem comes when they
get old and when they get old,
they get real dangerous
cause they get desperate.
They can't catch a deer anymore. So they
go for the easy, cool. Go for people.
People are easy, right? Yeah
man, your kids are easy.
I'm gonna go hiking with somebody slow
that's move. Go hiking with a small,
slow person. Someone who just doesn't
look like a challenge at all. Hey Man,
survival of the fittest. Go
smoking with someone who's smoking,
you're smoking the meat. It makes
it more attractive. So they're like,
what we eat affects how we taste.
It's got it. Right. So maybe,
maybe like people who are
in really in the junk food,
they'd be more attractive than a sweet
taste to them. Yeah, I bet. Right?
If you just eat candy all day,
I bet you taste delicious.
The human skittle attack the human
skittle over here. Leave me alone.
That fucking cat is so big, man.
Imagine just seeing the 115 pound cat
in the room with you. You'd be like,
oh Jesus Christ. Like my dog is probably
maybe 75 80 pounds somewhere in
that range. He's not marshal.
Yeah. And if he wanted to kill
me, he probably could. Right.
I mean, he's a golden retriever. They
don't kill anything other than squirrels.
But if he wanted to, I mean,
I don't know if he had that mentality
really was like crazy. Like,
like 28 days later he got that rage
virus in and he just went after me.
He's got giant ass fucking
teeth. Right? I mean,
I assume that I would kick his ass
because he listens to me because I'm his
daddy. You know what I mean?
Like there's no, he's never,
I've had pit bulls that grouch you a
little bit and you gotta Kinda like,
hey mother Fucker, I'm the
one who gives you your food,
cut the shit and then they'll give you
their Paul and then they're sorry you
played a little game with
them. A little dominance game.
Especially when they're teenagers
and they're like one and a half,
two years old. They'll test you just
to check cause it's natural for them.
It's natural for dogs. Golden's don't
ever do that. He don't grow out anybody.
They're just obedient, worst guard dog
of all time. You come over everybody.
He loves everybody. He
loves you. I love it.
He loves people like he's never like,
not, not like he's never met them,
but like he can't believe he
hasn't seen them in so long.
It's like a long lost friends.
The long lost friends.
Everyone's a long lost
friend. Hilarious. Everyone.
Everyone is a long lost friends.
What it's like with him,
he's such a love sponge. I would, I
would be jealous if I, if that's my dog,
I'm like, so I'm not special.
Just that motherfucker don't tell
dog jar really friendly dogs.
Every new person is another opportunity
for a new person to love them too.
And so they, they get so
excited to meet people.
Smart do when people come over to the
house, he is so hilarious. Everyone,
he loves everybody. Like
I believe it's, you know, like
whenever you met your daughter,
it's like a few years
and he just starts whining
and run around and start
goals. It's hilarious. But if you want
it to you probably kill me. I mean,
if a rat was that big, I would fucking
put my money on the rat on the right.
Right. And dogs, dogs
kill rats all the time.
Even those little dogs like Jack
Russells, those little tiny dogs,
those are designed to kill rats.
Hilarious. My ex had a dog, right?
And I was holding the dog and she got
into a car right across the street and
moved it and then got out the car and
Wa and the dog acted like he didn't just
see a jump in the car. He acted like
she went away for two days. It was a
[inaudible].
I was like, she just went to,
she just moved the car across
you and we watched her do it.
Do you remember when we had a, uh,
Mr. Foster Aaron Foster on the podcast
and he was talking about being able to
kill a wolf. We had to fight
one. We had to correct him.
We had to go press stop this. Don't, I
know you're a beast, but come on man.
Where people were made
out of like smush. Yeah.
Everything's smushy also song.
Yeah. Something that wants a bite.
Your tit like of a wolf.
Decide to bite your tit.
The amount of pain you'd
be in, be unbearable.
I know you feel like one of those buns
that they give you at the steak house.
That's what your flesh feels
like. Exactly. Like a steak house.
Been bred fucking Aaron Foster spent
four hours on Twitter explaining why he'd
beat a wolf one on one. He's hilarious.
Isn't he doing a podcast now? Yeah,
he's got his own podcast. He started
doing music, which is really good.
You just release some music under,
I think positive. He knows his name.
He's a visionary. He's
a running back. Yeah.
He was running tired to
hit a vegan running back.
He retired young and he's
fucking super smart man.
Just except in control when it comes
to someone when comes to walls,
I think he's trolling a little bit. He's
having a little fun. It's being smart.
Yeah. There's like a wolf
he could get. Not any wolf.
Like there's one out there.
You want it? Oh yeah. Yeah.
He could fuck up an old one.
A declawed one with no teeth or grandma
Woolf old one that doesn't have any
endurance anymore. It
would be a battle though.
Even then before we get too
far off of this, I just,
there's pictures on the Google
images sent me down this,
this is just north of the, uh,
Los Angeles Zoo. So there's a,
I think this might even be
that same chat we just saw.
So this chap cougar has some food.
It's eating. And then next picture,
the bear show up to take
it. And now wait a minute,
they're eating the fucking food
instead of the Cougar. Oh my God.
So this is near us to this 30
miles away or probably even closer.
So bare steel, deer from
cougars. This is what happens.
Liberals run a state. Listen
folks, I'm liberal. I'm with you.
I know a lot of you think I'm not.
There's a lot of knuckleheads out there.
That thing going part of
the alt right or something.
I vote left on fucking
everything. But you,
you gotta stop anthropomorphizing
animals. We gotta be careful.
We, I'm on team people. I don't
want these animals to die,
but I also don't want to go out to my
fucking swimming pool and see a bear in
there and they, they have
that in Pasadena. You've
seen that shit in Pasadena.
This family went outside and there's a
fucking bear swimming around their pool
or bears and Pasadena.
Big Ones like 200 pound bear
swimming in this motherfucker's pool.
Do I live here? How do,
how do I know this shit?
Not only that you got to take over, man.
If they decide that this is their spot,
look at this shit. Look, there's a few
of them. If you've got the whole family,
my God, how many bears
are in there? Oh my God,
dude, these are, these things are no joke.
The problem with bears is too,
once they get a spot where they know they
can get food or they can get water or
they can get something, they're
going to come back to that spot.
They get habituated. That's why
they have a real problem with them.
With the people. Yellowstone
used to feed them, you know,
people would pull in and then I
actually did that or was there when that
happened when I was a little
kid, I went to Yellowstone.
My parents took me when I was probably
like seven or eight years old and I
remember just thinking, this is so crazy.
You're in your car and the bears
are outside. They were right there.
They don't do it the
same way anymore though.
Now they discourage
human bear interaction.
They just didn't understand
it I think as well.
Which is kinda crazy cause
I were not that long ago.
I was looking at the 1970s I just don't
understand people's like for ferocious
animals, like I don't want to kill him,
but I never want to feed something
that could kill me. Well,
I think people have this really distorted
idea of wildlife because of movies.
If you thought about like
what the lion king is,
you would never want aligned to die,
you know, lines noble. I mean, sure,
there's a few bad ones, but
overall, the lion king's the,
he's the sweetheart. He's amazing.
You think about Yogi bear and
you think about teddy bears.
Kids have teddy bears. I mean,
we have this weird thing.
We take polar bears, which is
the most vicious of all bears,
and we have them be our friends
selling us ice cream and Coca-Cola.
They're selling Klondike bars. Yeah.
We cartoon them and then people grow up
watching these cartoons and think, oh,
let me go pick this friendly thing
that was drawn. But that's a,
I wish. A ferocious beast. Yeah.
I wish it didn't have a history if
we just thought of it as a thing,
like a wolverine. Right. Wolverines
don't have any, there was no one.
No one feels about a wolverine the
same way they think about a bear.
Cause there was no like cute wolverines.
There's only the ones that see in like a,
you know x men like Wolverine
dudes. This one. Yeah. Yeah.
But he's like a person.
His name's Wolverine.
There's no like cute wolverines cause
they're so fucking for Roche has such a
monster of a little animal. One
Wolverine will fuck up a big bear.
Oh for real dude. They're fucking
ruthless. They chase wolves off food.
How big a wolverine. Not Big
man. 40 pounds. 50 pounds. Jeez.
They'll fuck up everything.
They fuck up everything.
Everything runs away from them. They're
just ready to die all day, all day,
ready to die.
And they're super strong and durable
for a little tiny thing you ever see.
You know what a wolverine looks
like and now I think I don't go up.
A Wolverine bearing is fancy.
It looks like a fake animal.
So like a super jacked little
giant rat bear thing with fangs.
It's like a super, it's like a
super badger. Badgers are similar.
I know they vicious. Fucking vicious.
That's a wolverine. Jeez Bro.
I mean, look at the teeth on that
thing. Look at its face and that's it.
Smiling. Yeah, that's a good day.
Those motherfuckers are
ready to go to war all day.
Make weird noises. They're terrifying.
Like if that thing wanted to kill you,
you would be fucked. Look at
this closed claws and the teeth.
Now imagine that that thing is hyper
aggressive and it's a Predator and fuck,
that shit is built to survive. Fuck
man. That is a crazy little animal.
They are ferocious and they,
they are ready to go at all times and
they'll try to get the fuck away from you.
The animal scientific meat
name means the glutton.
That's a pretty apt
description. Four feet tall,
weighing 22 pounds for females
and 40 pounds for males.
This fierce creatures are the
largest members of the weasel family.
They're fucking weasels, bro.
That's vicious weasel still.
They're small compared to some of the
animals that they compete with for food.
But a wolverine has no problem standing
up to wolves or a bear when a meal is on
the line. And that crazy 40 pounds.
The way bears are to us is the
way we are the dogs. You know,
like an 80 pound dog probably. Fuck
you up if you're 150 pound person.
That's how wolverines are. The bears.
40 pound wolverine might fuck up a
200 pound bear bears. Like, damn,
this ain't worth it when I die. I want
to come back as a wolverine. Yeah,
that's a vicious animal. The Caribou,
the hairs and rodents as well as larger
animals like Caribou that are weak or
ill, but we'll also scavenge from any
car cause they can get their claws on.
They also eat vegetables and berries.
Frozen meat isn't a deterrent there.
Upper molar that sit
sideways at 90 degrees,
let's them rip into ice covered carcasses.
Their teeth are so sharp and strong
that they can even eat bones. Whoa.
Damn. Once they got food,
they often bury it to save for
later mere hours after a meal.
They'll go on the hunt again.
Ferocious, ferocious little fucks.
Ugliest Shit too. Yeah, so we don't
have a cutie Po, one of those cutie.
We'd be like to Wolverine.
Hi, Mr Wolverton.
I'm here to help you on
targe with to the forest.
Now they're here to eat your kids.
I'm waiting for some woman to bring one
on the plane as a support wolverine.
Oh yeah, for sure. Yeah, some
crazy. It's always a woman. Yeah.
And always one that's like over
50 and on all kinds of medication.
If you're a dude and you bring a wolverine
out of playing the beat and beat your
ass, um, has wolverine
ever killed a person?
There's some women that'll
get offended by that.
Why does it have to always be in women?
Is it you? It's not you. Right? Right.
I'm not talking about you.
Alright. Why getting personal? Why?
Why do we hope to be gender
specific? You know what I'm saying?
Like if I'm saying, oh, it's probably a
woman doesn't mean hey, no women, right.
It means it's probably really a
woman, right. Because being honest,
the peacock person, that was a woman,
that was a woman and then the the,
but in the [inaudible],
the defense of women,
a guy got an emotional support alligator.
Recently there was a guy and he's
an idiot. But I hear about that.
I'm wonder how many of those
people, including the peacock lady,
are doing it just for attention because
they know that people will talk about
it. I think people that have like,
I'm saw this girl and see
in San Diego, La Jolla,
she came to the restaurant with her
micro pig. That's not real. You know,
that's not real. They met,
they made those, yeah, coming.
She explained it to me. No,
she adopted a pig and then kept it and
then fed it and then drove some ungodly
amount of time, like two days to Texas
to drop it off at a pig sanctuary.
That's how crazy for
animals. Whitney Cummings.
So through Whitney I learned
that pigs are just pigs.
There's no micro pig. It's just a pig
that they don't feed. Oh. For Real.
For Real. So they just
starved it and it just says,
keeps them on getting big by not
giving it a lot of food in there. Cool.
Pawn it off on a sucker pig.
Exactly. Scotty eat. Exactly.
It's greedy little pig. Yeah. I
mean they're famous for getting fat.
That's what they love to do. So they'll
pawn it off on some person and then,
cause they can't afford not to feed it.
Another person doesn't know any better.
They think they're getting a micro pig.
Oh, it's give me small and cute forever.
Now you're going to have
a thousand pound pig.
If you give you feed it everything and
wants to eat, it's going to keep growing.
It's like, Damn I, how did my pig
grow supposed cause the sole pig,
there's no micro. It's like micro people.
Like if you look at people
from like the civil war day,
they were always 125
pounds. Well why was that?
Because they didn't have
any fucking food, man.
The same guy today probably
be 200 pounds. Yeah.
[inaudible] and all that stuff
and everything in it. Oh yeah.
Well even just eating regular food,
just like real meat and potatoes
and vegetables and shit.
You're not gonna be 125 pounds.
I was probably starving.
They probably didn't have three meals
a day back in the civil war era and
snacks. I read this book
by this, a pool hustler.
It was a McGurty life
of a billiard hustler.
I think it was so really interesting
book because it was about a guy who
survive by traveling around on trains,
like a Hobo gambling,
playing pool and billiards in the
depression. But during the depression,
he was talking about
almost starving to death,
like a people who would knock on people's
door and beg for Food and you know,
people would just come out with a
plate of food and give it to them.
Like everybody was like on the edge.
People had to really rely on people.
They didn't like rely on people for
food. There was no fucking jobs.
There's a lot of people
back then, you know, we,
we're looking at these homeless
folks and like for the most part,
my opinion is you're looking at,
people probably have an undiagnosed or
untreated mental illness. A lot of that.
I think it's a lot. I don't
know what the number is,
but I would think it's a lot.
And then there's also people that make
mistakes down the line and then people
that you know had terrible childhoods,
horrible abuse, sexual abuse,
violence, the evil parents.
You know, parents die,
leave him alone, foster
care, all that kind of shit.
And like it's not their
fault a lot of times.
And then as as humans we should do
something to, to take care of it.
But on the other hand, and we just
don't know who's who out there. Yeah,
exactly. Who's mentally ill, who just
needs help and dimensional people, man,
they need help too. But like how
do you force them to, you know,
how do you force them in it?
Oh, how do you just get them
real help so that because yeah,
the way they do help people with
pills and all that stuff. Some,
some of it works and some of it doesn't
work. [inaudible] you know what I mean?
And some of it's just like creates
a dependency on something. Yeah.
So it's just like the,
the system just from the beginning needs
to be fixed and not just like pills
and,
right. Have you ever been on any
kind of psych medication? No.
Have you ever taken an Adderall? No. Me
Neither. I want on to though. You do.
Jamie gave me a little bit of Adderall
once allegedly. And uh, I didn't take it.
I looked at it and was
like, I don't do it man.
Go and gave it to you cause I haven't
taken it either. I had it for a long time.
I was like, I don't think I'm
going to take it. You want it.
It's just I've, I've known so many people
that do it and they get real weird.
They get weird. And it is a, it's,
it's an amphetamine and
when you take amphetamines,
especially if you don't take
amphetamines responsibly,
really strange things happen.
And one of the things happen
is people get really paranoid.
They get really weird. They get,
they start having delusions of grandeur.
They start thinking that what
they're doing is very important.
That a lot of people are out
to take them down. And uh,
you see that with people that,
that do too much Adderall,
they don't follow the prescription. They
just start chewing them all day. Whoa.
Things can get real slippery,
like slippery. It's like
a mess slipper. That's how
the hurts because they,
I guess they get immune to it. So they
gotta take extra. Oh yeah, you did.
And then then the more you
take, the worse it gets.
Yeah. Tolerance
is a real for everything.
Yeah. I would assume. I mean,
they even have tolerances for
snake venom. You know, the,
one of the things that snake handlers do,
they'll give themselves a
little bit of Adam every day.
Oh mom sells immune to snake venom.
Your body's an amazing adaptable thing,
which is why vaccines work.
Right? So why these crazy fucks?
It don't want us to have
vaccines like, listen, you know,
we gotta be real careful with
claiming expertise on this shit.
We gotta be real careful with getting
fucked over by pharmaceutical companies
and big business. We gotta
be real careful of that too.
But we also gotta be real careful of
not listening to these doctors and
researchers that are struggling to
find the ways to cure these horrible
infectious diseases. Cause they've got
a lot of them nailed through vaccines.
It's so confusing out there. You can
make an argument for on any team chore,
Anything You can cause. It's tough to
figure out. I know a lot of logical,
intelligent people that,
that think that vaccines cause autism
and I'm not a doctor so I don't know if
you know that. Yeah, I think,
I think none of Doctor Ah,
um, puts, uh, I've heard logical,
intelligent people argue that that
vaccines can cause autism. I'm like, man,
you're not a scientist.
Like how could you say that?
Cause you saw it in a documentary.
I know it's interesting when you see
something in the documentary that sounds
good. You want to relate. It's fact.
I'm as guilty as that as anyone.
Probably more guilty than most.
I'm guilty of doing that a lot,
but just recognizing that over time I've
gotten to this point where I'm like,
maybe I should just shut the fuck up
about something that I don't actually know
about and try to figure out what it is
instead of saying what it is, what they,
what they do know is that vaccines have
stopped the spread of a fucking bunch of
awful disease. Saved a bunch of plagues,
small pox that Lindsay Fitz Harris
woman who's been on the podcast,
Jamie, she sent me some image
of a, some people with smallpox,
bunch of stuff about small smallpox is
her riffing just horrific with how it
kills you. Her riffing,
they nip that shit in the
bud with vaccines. Maybe.
Maybe they've changed. Maybe,
maybe some vaccines do get people autism.
That's what that guy's back looks
like. Can maybe some vaccines,
vaccines do give some
people autism, but overall,
most of the time it helps everybody.
Like there's going to be some things
that affect people differently,
but then that,
but that means you can't stop
taking it or giving it to everybody.
That's no constellation happen. Right.
It's no constellation if you get autism
from it or if your child and talk to
them from it. Yeah, but it's
one of those things that's bad.
Everybody grows up without
it. Right. You know,
it's a messy thing about
peanut person, right?
Like this not is not like clean pro.
Like are you pro abortion? Well,
I'm pro abortion up to
a point. Right? Right.
When it gets to be like seven
months, it's that seems to, you know,
it gets longer in the pregnancy.
That seems like if you're talking about
like the first few days, right? Yeah.
What do you, what is that like
three cells, pro abortion.
If I get the girl pregnant,
you know, as far as it takes.
As far as the text. Yeah. It's
um, it's a weird, you know,
with many, many, many subjects. There's
like a weird, well, it's not exactly,
well, it's this, you know, if
there's a vaccine court for reason,
vaccines have done damage to people.
People gotten injured from vaccines
where during the injection site something
happened.
Peter Hotez was talking about that
he's a doctor that's a specialist in
infectious diseases and vaccines and
he was explaining that there's five
environmental factors that they think
were five factors they think contribute to
a child possibly getting autism.
They've narrowed it down to these
things with the most current research,
but they're all during the womb. It's,
it's contact with things during the
womb or in the genetics of the mother.
They think that it has something to do
with the developmental process while the
child is in vitro in the
woman's body, not after birth.
They don't think it occurs after
birth, but I don't know that.
I mean they could be wrong.
Then it could be current and then they
could change that opinion a year from
now. They can find new evidence. That
shit happens all the time. Yeah, exactly.
It really does. It happens all the time,
but what we have to do is make sure we
have fucking people that are working on
this shit,
trying to figure out the
way to stop diseases because
otherwise some Spanish flu
type shit comes rolling around all
the bullshit and kill everybody.
That Spanish flu killed
millions and millions of people.
The 1920s sound lethal at all. It's
just Spanish flu. It's just like,
how did that kill people?
Sounds like a drink. Yeah.
To bring that full circle back to
downtown la or that typhus outbreaks have
happened. Just a couple of [inaudible].
Same thing as typhoid fever I think,
but it's a very close to
new one. It's a new one.
It's a new typhoid that they
don't have a fucking vaccine for.
I was down there the other day
just trying to buy donuts downtown.
It's the allure of downtown
has escaped me. Everybody.
Everybody thinks it's amazing with Jamie
and I talked and we've been talking
about this forever, we wanted
to get a loft in downtown,
like up high and start filming podcasts
up there because I think that would be
the coolest backdrop like for Youtube,
like you and me sitting
here and behind us.
You just all building by
sometimes square MTV shit,
whites and shit like that would be an
amazing backdrop for a podcast screen that
now be safe. Yeah, can't do that.
If I was going to green screen something,
it would be like current events, Shit.
It would be like Melania Trump
slapping dog's hand away. I'd be like,
did you see that shit? Like
that would be what I would,
I wouldn't pretend I'm in the savannas
and a man like behind me is the Cheetah
creeping up on me and everybody
sees it like does he know? He know
I'll be sitting in Griffith Park. Behind
me is a mountain lion munched on a leg.
I was meditating in
Griffith Park. Oh Dude.
Like one morning and I hear rustling in
the bushes and it was a coyote like just
waking up. They bite you. Yeah. And
I was like, I can't do that anymore.
Close my eyes and Griffith Park.
Yeah. You go camping out there,
they'll bite you. They'll
check that you might be dead.
They'll take a bite if you
just lie in there like damn.
Maybe he just recently died. Yeah,
they really well they
really well their predators.
That whole thing is so strange. He
people are so strange how we just a,
we think it's cool.
It's cool to be around these
bears and mountain lions and shit.
And we have urban Cairo.
These ones that like you'll see
walking down the street at night. Yeah.
My neighbor had two little dogs
and one of them was really old,
so then she had to walk them one at a
time because she saw a coyote one time
coming up on him and she couldn't
handle both of them. So she takes,
or she used to take each dog out
to a walk at night. One at a time.
Take a gun. Shit. That fucking rotten
dog right in the face. It's hot.
That's what a coyote is. A dog. Not her
dog. I was talking about the coyote,
but actually that's a wolf. It's a
small wolf. It's a small wolf. Yeah.
Coyote is like a particularly
durable and resilient form of Wolf.
So shitty wolf. It's a
really interesting wolf.
There's a great book called Coyote
America by uh, Dan Flores. Um, he,
I learned about him through my friend
Steve and now I think he was his professor
and one of his, um, one of
his courses. Um, but he is a,
a guy who spent an extreme amount of
time studying the history and the science
behind coyotes for really,
really interesting book.
But one of the things they found
out is that when you kill a coyote,
they just make more coyotes to them.
Like they know they spread out. Yeah.
They, when they yell out, they'd yell out.
They communicate in a
lot of different ways.
The yell out when they kill something,
sometimes they yell out when they're
trying to figure out where each other's
are. And they also yell at like a
roll call. Like, cause you know,
it's hard out there. So they're
like, hey, what's up Jamie?
Jamie, they do that. That's part of what
they're doing. And when one is missing,
they, the female,
there's some sort of a
chemical or biological reaction
and her body makes more
puppies. Oh, she says like we're fucking
tonight. Yeah, I didn't hear Jamie.
We're fucking tonight. They
make larger litters fam.
So if a normal litter would be like
four pups, if someone's missing,
they'll make six or eight
something along those lines.
And now we can't kill them while they
spread out to in the 17 hundreds and 18
hundreds you know when people's first
started going through the west, their,
you know, they were around. But
then when we started killing them,
they spread to the entire country. They
all said they weren't single state.
So they weren't like down this way.
No, no, no. They weren't everywhere.
They're a west animal. They were western
animal. And then they went proud.
They're in New York City.
Oh Shit. For Real. Yes. For Real.
There's coyotes in New York City.
They have little packs of them
running around Times Square.
Get outta here bro. For real dude.
There's little coyotes that are
wandering through central park.
Listen, I get that there's
mountain lions in Griffith Park.
I get that there's cause
urban car, but New York City,
I might've made up the time square part.
Brick best bananas. Definitely York.
I'll check. I know they're in
New York cause there was a,
they probably came from upstate.
They've seen them in buildings.
[inaudible] coyotes and
abandoned buildings where
they've decided to make all
the cup Nass and abandoned belt. They're
all, they're all over downtown La Fam,
central park, central park, Bam, coyote
motherfucker. Damn Bro on the streets.
Coyote. Okay. On the street.
So I was telling the truth,
they could go to times square
easily everywhere. I've gotta look,
I'm almost like a tour agitating
coyote that has a small wolf.
That's what that is. And there
we've were infected with them.
And here's the thing. This is
what you have to be aware of.
That's the gentleman that, uh, go back.
What is his name? Justin Brown. Yeah.
Justin Brown was on the podcast. He
tracks coyotes all throughout downtown La.
He's biology, a wildlife biologist
that works for the state.
Really interesting in downtown La.
So instead of like being at a ranch
outside of Bakersfield and attach a pea
mountains, this guy is a look. There's
a coyote. Same trap. Same camera trap.
Got that? Yeah. Get a picture of that
too young James, order that bitch up.
Make a note. Yeah. Look why not. Right.
We should have coyote picture too.
We can't just have a mt line. That's rude.
Let's show all the crazy
shit that's wandering.
See if they got a bear and the
camera trap. Hopefully they got a,
coyotes are so used to being around that.
The way they walk down the street
is just like regular. Yeah.
Like no trepidation whatsoever.
Look at that. Just wandering. Yeah.
Yeah. Whistle them. Walk.
I remember in 1994 the first,
it might've been 93 first time I ever
came to La and I was staying at the a
Oakwood gardens or
Oakwood apartments. Yeah,
on Barnum there in Burbank.
They're furnished departments where it's
where you stay when you first come to
la. You don't have a spot.
You don't have enough money to get up
and you don't know if the show you're on
is ever going to last.
So I stayed at these Oakwood's apartments
and I was driving up the street to the
apartment and I saw coyotes. I
was like, what is this dog doing?
Just wandered around and I was
like, Oh shit, those are coyotes.
I couldn't believe it. That's fine.
I pulled over and I'm looking out the
window. There's three little wolves.
Isn't it funny how that moment when
something you never seen before,
you see it and it takes you a second
to realize what it is and then you,
the word for what it is comes
to your head right away.
Like you knew it was a coyote even
though you've never really seen a coyote
before. I was in denial. He was in
denial. Yeah. I was thinking it was a dog.
Like it was three dogs.
Then I had to pull over
and I'm like, I remember
people telling me they'd seen coyotes,
but I thought it was like
I saw a mountain lion.
Like if some of these I saw a mountain
and you're like Holy Shit you did.
That's pretty rare, right?
Have you ever seen one? No,
I've seen to a live. Yeah. See two
live ones like out there. Yeah.
And what happened? One of them ain't
my dog cause when I lived in Colorado,
yeah. And you was right there. No, no, no.
I was this mountain lion was
case in the house I think. Right.
And we saw it in the woods
at one point in time.
And then another one I saw in Santa
Barbara in Montecito driving through a
neighborhood and saw this
animal run across the car
in front of the lights and I
saw its tail and I was like, Holy
Shit, that's a cat. I take it back.
I have seen some outlines really,
you know, phase on love. Yeah.
He moves all over the place. But
one time he lived in San Diego,
me and Hugh more went to visit him
and we is at his house hanging out.
And then at night he was like, look
out the window in his backyard.
And there was like mountain
lions in his fucking backyard.
Yeah. There was like two or three of
them and all I'm thinking is like,
how the fuck are we going
to get to the car? Oh, like,
and he was so casual about it
and I was like, wow. Yeah. Yeah.
It's time to move son. Yeah. Um, Jamie,
did you ever see that video from Colorado
where a guy looked out his window?
There was three mountain
lions on his driveway.
He's like super clear iPhone footage
and this guy a or android phone,
I don't know. I want to
use, could be an android.
He was saying this weekend he takes more
shit for using an android phone than
for being a Vegan,
for being a black Vegan and
what else can media could be.
Yeah, yeah. You get more grief
forever than android phone. Yeah.
It's a weird little battle. Right. It's
like Republican, Democrat type Shit.
Yeah, it is. It is like people with
iPhone really ain't trying to have it,
but it's not just that.
It's like there's teams.
It's like the fucking Orioles were
playing the Yankees. You know,
people get on a Goddamn team and the
iPhones are the Yankees right now.
It's weird. Band phone. The
phone thing is a weird thing.
It's weird that people are so,
they're, they're really like so tribal.
But their tribal with their phone.
Yeah. They made a tribe out of phones.
People could make a tribe out of anything.
[inaudible] and what's really
crazy is the biggest company,
the ones that's the most desirable is
a company that also makes computers and
they, they make their own chip.
They make their own hardware. Right?
Like that's what's really strange
about apple. Like they make everything,
they make the software, they
make the hardware. They the only,
there's only one, you'll have different
models, but there's only an iPhone.
You get an iPhone or XR,
whatever the fuck it is.
X Excess Max. But it's only an iPhone.
That's all you get. You don't get it.
You don't get anything else.
Whereas android you got
of brands. See the so much
variety everybody. Yeah,
but truth rough. Jamie's like
that. But you gotta have,
you gotta be able to deal with that
green when the green light comes in and
protects them. I was
offended by the green bubble.
I have friends that I go up on the
little screen. Even smart people,
I'm like, we've got them
on. They fucking green.
But maybe if they're smart and your
bubble comes a green, it means something.
It doesn't look green to
them. That's a thing. Yeah.
Mine and is pretty cool looking.
Yeah. All my Texas, when they come in
like they're all, what do they look
like? Is there a show you see a prophecy?
Well, I think mine minor.
Oh, they're blue. Yeah. Blue.
So here's come in blue anyway, so it looks
blue. What? Do you have a note? Yeah,
a galaxy note note nine. Yeah.
That's the Shit I have no, those,
that's my other phone. Yeah, he told
me. Yeah. That thing is bad ass. Yeah.
It is a beast of a phone.
That screen is amazing. Yeah.
It's so big and you like you get
the whole screen, there's no cutout.
Yeah. And it goes down the side and shit.
But I got it just in case like I'm on a
flight and I want to watch something on
it or just somewhere you want
to watch something on it,
you download it and you gotta have a
full screen instead of having like a
getting the iPad on top of that
because people have just too much shit.
Do you ever use the pen though?
That pen is useless to me. Yeah.
I would just like, like signed
the document today. Like yeah,
like Shaundra needed a w nine
signed a w nine form from me.
I just like downloaded it, signed
it and then emailed it back. Wow.
Yeah. I've never used it.
Yeah. Maybe it's just me.
I draw dicks on people's head.
That's a perfect use for it.
But I also feel like a rebel when
I use my android phone. I do.
It's hilarious. I feel like a
rebel fucking, I'm crazy man.
Fucking trans out here. Woo.
When do you use your android?
Like, like, so you'll have your iPhone.
So when do you need more? More often?
I'm transition out of one phone number
to another, which I have to do often. Oh,
okay. Yeah. So you have two different
numbers? Yeah. Okay. Getting used to it.
Play. I played with it a lot. They
got a new one that's coming out.
There's a new ones coming out that looks
amazing. Do you have 10? No. 10 yeah,
it's coming out like in a couple of
weeks. Yeah. I try to hold on to it.
I don't try to get every new phone.
I try to hold onto it for a minute.
So I feel like they didn't rip me off
and then maybe three or two phones later,
then I'll get the other one. But
if I buy every phone, I feel like
I want to be a rebel
within the rebel, you know?
He's saying I'll get some old
shit. Yeah. I got some old shit.
You're not gonna get me like
in this loop. But just buying,
buying by comparison. Yeah. That's
in a weird thing. Like that phone,
they could stop right there. That
phone's perfect. Like it does everything.
Yeah. What more do I need? They
take some pictures, makes videos,
get on the Internet, ask you questions,
gives me answers, send emails.
What the fuck else do I need?
Don't you don't you don't.
It does everything unless they come up
with some new shit. But if someone said,
Hey Ian, I'll give you $1 million,
but you gotta use that phone only for
the rest of your life. What'd you say?
Yes. This one? Yes. That's crazy, right?
Yeah, the breaks. We'll replace
it, but that's your phone forever.
I know it. I know it will slow down.
Well apple phones will slow down because
they engineered them and that made me
sick. That almost made me stop
using apple stuff. I was like,
I can't believe that you
guys are attributing this
to battery life that that's
in disingenuine. Then they admitted
it, right? Well they admitted it,
but they said they did it so that it would
give you more battery life cause your
battery degrades over time. So they
engineered it. That is a convenient,
they also must have understood that people
were going to get frustrated with the
fact that it's slowed down considerably
and they would give them an incentive to
buy a new phone to say that they
didn't say that like, come on,
you guys are so God damn smart. You make
iPhones. They figured out everything.
Yeah, but not that you didn't figure that
out. You figured that out on purpose.
You also are one of the most
successful businesses of all time.
Apple has billions of dollars
cash just sitting there.
They have so much money.
Pablo Escobar buried money.
They got so much money.
Apple is something like how many billions
of dollars is apple has 225 billion.
Apple has so much cash
cash that they could,
they could probably
wipe out half our debt.
This is what they could buy right now
and still have 25 billion leftover.
They could buy Nike, Ferrari, Twitter,
the Manchester United Franchise and
the Manchester United football team and
still have a, how much
left? 25 billion left.
I say football for people like yourself
that are fishing up. Thank you sir.
I didn't say soccer. I appreciate
that. Do they say soccer? Um,
where are you from originally? Uh,
in England? Yeah. No, not in England.
And they know it's football. Yeah.
Only in America they say soccer.
But before that, like where did it,
where did it become football?
Was it always football in Europe?
It was always football. Well
why, why when it came over here,
did it switch over? No idea.
Why didn't they come up with another
name for Pho? We ever kick a foot.
Paul, I think, I think they were
playing football, like the soccer,
football,
and then somebody picked up the ball
and started running with it and they
started tackling each other. Like
I heard some story like that. Huh?
And then they kind of created
football and it evolved from there.
But then they never changed the name.
Isn't it weird that like football is
called football when the only person who
kicks it is a guy who
can't even play the game,
the least significant person on the team
as far as getting pussy when there's a
championship. Yes. It is weird. Yeah.
And you're not allowed
to hit him. Right, right.
And you're not allowed to hit him.
Yeah. That's crazy. You can hit him.
It's not while he's in motion of his, a
vulnerable person to try to be safe. Oh,
so you can't hit them all once. Legs up
in the area. Oh, that's so ridiculous.
What a bitch house rule.
If you blow off the ball,
you have to block the ball
and then you get hit him yet.
But in the crazy that that's football.
It's only one time it gets kicked.
Right. How was that football? Why? Why?
What a silly name. Right.
Does it make sense?
But I'm not mad at it. You know,
it's like fine. It's whatever.
Imagine if they called, you know,
baseball, what would they call it?
Foul. If they called it
foul. We're playing foul.
It's something that
happens every now and then.
This game has nothing to do
with running around the basis.
It's about touchdowns. She'd call
it touchdown play. Touchdown it.
Cause it's just, you know, baseball.
It's just like we're trying to
get from base to base. Yeah.
If they call it baseball touchdown.
No, they call it football. Touchdown.
Touchdown. The NTL national
touchdown league. We're going to,
we're going to play
touchdown. That's the game.
It's not football with your foot.
Doesn't have shit to do with it or an
explanation of why we call it soccer and
it's more confusing than
we care to go through.
When you go back to England,
if you're from England and you
talking about it to people,
do they resent the term soccer? Like
how does that work? Some people do.
Like I used to present the
term soccer. Really? Yeah.
But I live here and it's like get
over it. You know what I'm saying?
As a person, I got to get over it cause
it was my favorite sport growing up,
so I just got over it. And then now I
even call it soccer. My podcast is soccer.
I don't even say football, but
when I go to England I just, Oh,
just when I'm around
football, soccer people,
I say football, I get
it. Yeah. It's like if I,
if I was talking to someone that they
wanted to talk about pool but they wanted
to call it bumper pool. Okay.
The woman's World Cup,
they won the World Cup and a
United States did for soccer and,
but it's not, you know, it's football
to people like yourself World Cup.
Like how can they call the
world cup soccer to a piece
to one country that gives
the least amount of flux about the
sport right now. Weird. That's weird.
That's the power of America. That's crazy.
If you really stop to think about it,
we made them change the name of
their thing, but we're like, ah,
we're not going to get in there. We'll
call it soccer. Okay. We're a card of it,
but we're calling it this, they call it,
did they call it football in like
Argentina? Yeah. Okay. Everywhere.
Futball you know,
but it's football to start their
pronunciation and spelling of it.
But then Australia, they're the
rebels. The rebels. Oh yeah.
They have their own rules.
They have structure and the rules flip
all they changed the rules for more
ruggedness. Yeah. Cause they're too.
You know what? It was over there.
They were too used to rugby. Like
those New Zealand savages. Yeah. Yeah.
They're fucking savage. You can't play
that bitch ass game when a helmet,
these guys are running around biting
each other in the Dick and the scrums.
Right. That's the most
rugged game. Anything to win.
That's the game they
should play in America.
All the CTE problems they're having you.
You'd have a little bit of that with,
with anything. Contact Sports,
you're going to get injuries [inaudible]
but I think you'd have less with no
gear. So both those things confuse me.
I don't know the difference between
rugby on Australian rules football and I
think in Australia they
play both. Yes. Yes.
I'd be just confused like what is the
difference? Well the ball's different,
right? They both seem like,
what's a rugby ball look like?
Literally look about the
same. Is it? No different.
Not Note at there is slight differences,
but they look about the same.
It's like a football with more rounded
edges and it's a little more plump as far
as I know. They could be playing with a
round ball. I literally don't even know.
Yeah, I have no idea what a
rug now it's kind of like,
it kind of looks like
an American. That's it.
That's a cross between a basketball and
a football. It's like a fat football.
Yeah. So that's an Australian use football
though. It's similar to a rugby ball.
Okay. So that's not a foot
rugby ball, but it's close.
So there's probably like
football, Australian rules,
football and then rugby ball. Right. What
is the rules? What can they do? Yeah.
What are they doing different?
It's also sometimes referred to in
the media as the round ballgame.
The world game and international football.
Australian was football referred
to as Australian football. Hmm.
I think that's a little more like fluid.
Like the game does stop as much as less
stoppages to kind of just keep going.
Okay.
It says it's a little more fluid where
players can pretty much run around where
they choose. They still have a
specific end side goal to score,
but it's more open in between.
Another main differences that the
game is played in 20 minute quarters,
not halves. Hmm. I was trying,
I told you a couple while ago,
they're adding three verse
three basketball to the
Olympics coming up and the
way that that game is played is so
different than traditional basketball.
Like it's just a running clock.
Once you score you just take it out,
throw it background across the line,
go score again, it's very fast paced.
So they bring in like pock ball
to the Olympics? I think so.
It apparently it's very popular in Europe.
It's not like that big three
basketball that sort of started here.
It's not that same basketball,
but it's popular I guess
when will Harris was in here.
Will Harris has this a show
called anatomy of a fighter.
He's a videographer and he went to
Dagestan to watch Khabib. Norman Madoff,
who's the UFC lightweight champion
who's fucking animal man. He just,
he's one of the rare undefeated top
of the food chain fighters in MMA.
They play a game of basketball in Dagestan
where they don't dribble the ball at
all. They just like wrestle
each other to the ground.
And even choke each other and get each
other in armbars and shit so that they're
just practicing Jujitsu. Yeah,
there will look. They don't,
they don't dribble it all.
They're basically playing
like ball a football type,
but they're shooting at the basketball
hoop but they throw each other to the
ground. And Khabib, we'll fucking
hip toss dudes cause they,
they have it right next
to the wrestling mats.
So part of what they filmed was he was
in a wrestling match with this dude when
they were trying to take a player out.
So he's grabbed a hold of this dude
and when he grabs a hold as dude,
he drags him to the ground and get
him it back, gets him in a harm bar,
gets them in a rear
naked choke. It's crazy.
Macy guy tap and he doesn't let him
up. Like here it goes, look, look.
He grabs them like they're allowed
to do this. The guy slips through,
he gets them, they're
grappling. First of all,
they're grappling on the fucking hardwood
floor, full blast glock grappling.
And then he takes him to the
ground. Like this is serious.
This isn't playing around.
He takes the dudes back.
Now they're on the floor again.
They're on the hardwood floor and
he's fucking choking them out.
Just kind of McGregor them and then
they keep going and as they keep going,
he's getting the guy in an armbar
later. This is, this is this,
this is basketball for white dudes
that can't dribble. That's all.
This is just like how do
we, but I don't know man.
I think this is the most effective
way to use wrestling with basketball.
I think they just wanted to make something
that's like a really hard workout
that's very competitive. I think I,
I don't know if other people are doing
this in Europe or if this is just
something that Dagestan
figured out, but look,
these are some of the most savage
fighters in the UFC. It does look fun.
It looks fun. As far as, yeah, I assume
I should get Khabib on your back.
They just don't have access to a very
good basketball and pump to keep it pumped
up on the floor is probably
not good to be dribbled on.
So they just figured out a better game
to play instead of dealing with that
fucked up on court. That's a
ridiculous way to think. Jamie.
These are world class fighters.
They travel over the world.
They have all sorts of gym equipment,
they have mats, they have weights,
they have everything skin on it.
That's a shitty basketball played
with lots of basketballs in my life.
You would never even try to dribble that
missing line to another like American
football slash Jujitsu. Slash Ben.
A lot of balls to like if you
have a dead spot on a court,
you almost don't want to play on it.
But dude, they could get another ball.
They all have brand new sneakers
on and leggings and shit.
I mean it's not like DAC stands
in the middle of nowhere.
I don't get goods there. They could, but
they might just like this game better.
They're just like, fuck it. We're playing
this cause we're all better at this.
That I think, I think it helps them.
I'm saying that your leg made you
go one on one with the basket.
Maybe I did not understand
the rules. They make them up.
You said it was like I was swearing
for no reason. Oh, they're there.
Like they're, they're
talking out a dispute. Yeah.
How would you argue with Cabebe? You can,
that's the top dog as the beast
of the fucking crew. Um, but yeah,
which it's weird with what people
that get really into, like cricket,
cricket is one that the Europeans
brought over to India, right.
They brought it to the western days.
They brought it to any country that they
colonize and all those countries love
it and they play it. Oh.
So it's a colonization game and
then nowadays you have like,
almost like the equivalent of like world
cups of cricket and all the countries.
Australia is a big
cricket country because they in that,
so it's a big thing of west in these and
everything. Strange looking game too.
Right? It's just boring. Takes,
takes days to play sometimes
days. Yeah. Days. Yeah.
For a week I think sometimes.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, one game. Yeah.
How many hours a day? Long. Too many.
Oh my God. It's too many, man. I,
I, I used to kill me. It was fun
to play in a backyard because it's,
you can just get some sticks and stick
them in the ground and then put one
across the top as a wicked. This
is a game I would have no idea.
I couldn't even draw you a picture
of what the stick looks like.
Three sticks, three sticks, three sticks.
And then you put like one on top across
the, all of them send out when the,
you're out when the guy who's pitching
or Bolan and you swing in or if you don't
swing and it hits the wicked
and they knock over a comp,
kinda like bowling sticks,
then you're out. But yeah,
and then you get points that you hit
it. Trying to protect the wicked,
protect the wicked and hit it so far
that you can run from stick to stick.
You and your partner who's
batting at the other end,
and then the most amount of runs you
can get that just adds to the score.
Can I see that? I want to see
that. That sounds so weird.
Pull up a video of dudes playing cricket
like I've ever watched it go. Yeah,
I think I've seen like
highlights on television maybe.
You know it's funny that you never
seen cricket. Not a fucking get no,
no chance. I don't know. See I'm
already stunned by their outfits. Yeah.
Got An have nothing on. Some
dudes are covered up in gear.
Those that are that the guys with the
helmets cause the ball is hot as fuck.
I got hit by a cricket ball by the
strongest kid in school on time. Oh.
Then as I come down the way they
throw it, this was so weird.
Well I like the guys in the outfield
don't have anything cause I just catch the
ball bare handed, right?
Yeah. Bare handed. Yeah.
And I feel like they should have met.
He throws it, he runs at you [inaudible]
he runs and literally tries
to hit you with the ball.
That's crazy. And then does it have to
hit the ground first? Is that the deal?
Yeah, I think, yeah it does. It does.
From what I remember
because it seems like it,
but the dude like runs across the
line. This is a bullshit game.
Some 100% bullshit game. Like, I don't,
I'm not a big fan of baseball.
I used to be like, yeah,
I think it's kind of boring. My wrestling
coach used to say, it's not a sport,
it's a skills game to skills
game. It's not a sport.
You ever see a baseball path so
fucking tired. He had to push himself.
I had to push coach Murphy
wrestling coach in high school.
Also the same guy tried to get me to
play football when I weighed 135 pounds.
Crazy ass all. Yeah, maybe saw some
natural athlete Shit in, you know,
I just thought it was mean. Oh yeah.
That was mean. I'd been to be good.
Those mean I don't know the wrestler
because you put them in a great
safety. Probably just fucking
people up. I would get crippled.
That's what would have happened. The
dude on our team, his name is Bob Baker,
he weighed a good solid 300
pounds, so big. Maybe not,
maybe I'm exaggerating, but he was two
50 he was our heavyweight and I was like,
how? How is he and me?
How are we going to play the same
game where he could just run me over?
What did he want you to play? I Dunno.
We didn't even, just didn't get that far.
I'm like, you're crazy. I
was already fighting too.
I was doing martial arts and wrestling
at the same time like, look man, I can't,
I don't know. I'm not doing that. I'm
already doing shit. That freaks me out.
Physical shit scares the
shit out of me all the time.
I don't want to get scared
by even bigger people.
At least martial arts and wrestling
was confined to your own weight class.
You know if I had a wrestle
some Badass dude, at least, uh,
it was my own weight
class, you know? Yeah.
This is like the weight scale is all over
the place on the football field. Yeah,
man. It's all over the place and the
athleticism is all over the place too.
You know, you can get a guide
like Hershel Walker and you know,
if you're in high school and there's a
Herschel Walker in high school and he's
on some team that your opposing
good luck, fuck face this,
this people that are just
superior, just superior.
It's not a damn thing you can do about it.
There are people like that in martial
arts, like when you're all wrestling.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. There's things
like that and outliers. You know,
there's outliers in all sports and a
lot of it has to do with what you did
growing up.
Sometimes people do things grown up
like a lot of wrestlers turns out like
working on farms as a kid is a great
way for wrestlers to be super strong.
You know who's who make good restless
cowboys. Oh yeah. Because they, they,
they, you know, they stare at their,
get the cow fucking cow to the ground.
They do it all the time. They practice
on them. Yeah. Yeah, for sure.
We'll also, they're tough cause
you're gonna get banged up a lot.
And then a lot of it is like
mental toughness, you know,
but people who have to cat, like
there's a dude, Matt Hughes,
he was like one of the greatest Walter
wards of all time and he was ungodly
strong dude from Illinois on the
farm on a farm wrestling animals.
I was at a party one time, right?
I was at a party one time and he was
thrown by these rappers I used to write on
this show. There's this
lounge. So one of the rappers,
master fool dude from Brooklyn was friends
with these cowboy. It's a great name,
master fans. The fool, he
was dope to me. He's like,
he's like the flavor flavor of the,
the up the rappers for that group.
And he's just like, he's
just talks to everybody.
So he became friends with these cowboys.
They came to visit La for a week and live
in the house with the rappers and you
know, they were real
cowboys. They're like,
have that last Sue's out on
the set and shit like that.
So then at the party,
this black dude with dreads got into a
argument with one of the cowboys and be
like, we're not gonna fight in the house.
So everybody walks around the corner
to the street and in five seconds that
cowboy had the black dude
with dreads tied up with his pants,
just this tucked like twisty tied his body
and had him on the ground bleeding
Jesus. And then it was like, all right,
let him up and let's start again.
And he got up and he just did it to
the black dude again. And I was like,
I'll never fuck with a cowboy
if, if a cowboy is a wrestler,
like if he knows how to Russel
too. Both of those things. Yes,
wrestlers are so God damn strong.
You don't realize until they grab you and
then you realize how helpless you are.
So weird feeling. And even if you,
you can wrestle if you'd like.
I wasn't a good wrestler in high
score, but I made it to the states.
And, uh, I remember when, uh,
I was wrestling this kid who eventually
became friends with, cause he's,
he used to come to nautilus plus,
which was a place where I was teaching
taekwondo and we ran into each other when
we were both like 20, like
probably 20 or something like that.
It was really cool. It was a really
nice guy. His name is Murphy too.
I don't remember his first
name. It might've been,
that might've been his first name.
A lot of Irish people named Murphy,
like the most common name
amongst Irish people probably.
But uh, I was like doing pretty
good in like regional shit.
But this guy got ahold of
me and I was like, fuck.
She just made me realize like this
is another level of wrestling.
He had been wrestling all of his life.
I'd only been doing it for a year.
He just ragdoll on me around. I was
like fuck. And he wasn't even like,
like a champion. Yeah. I
don't think he won the states.
And then whoever did win the
states didn't win the nationals.
So it was like there's
this like tears to evals.
And then like a national high school
champion Ain't shit compared to a division
one NCAA Amir, all
American college wrestler,
those college wrestlers are off the chain
and then they ain't shit compared to
like Jordan burrows. It's not that
they're not shit. I shouldn't,
I never say that about,
I mean just saying that in comparison
because I admire them almost more than any
other athlete because there's no
professional venue for what they do.
One of the more amazing
things about wrestling is the
go into it knowing there's
no professional sport. There's
no perfect other than, you know,
pro wrestling is different.
It's, it's entertainment,
but there's no professional, 135
pound wrestling, 180 pound rep,
there's not an that. They just love it.
They just love it and it's the
toughest thing to do physically.
They're fucking animals.
But then when you get to the top
of the top of the food chain,
like a multiple time world
champion like Jordan burrows,
he had a wrestling match with Ben Aspirin
and he just ran him over just over.
And Ben is one of the best
grapplers to ever compete in MMA.
And he was also a two time Olympian.
The rest of them. Yes. And that guy,
he ran him over and Ben asked her and
runs most people over when he wrestles
with them. Yeah. Levels, levels, levels.
It's never ends with speaking Avastin.
Is he awake? He's awake. We can talking.
He's a, he handled it
like a champion. Yeah.
He a went on a Ariel Helwani show and
talked about it and just said that, yeah,
it sucks that the guy's a douchebag if
you're feeling like sucks losing to him.
Uh, you know, I don't like them. He said,
uh, you know, he just, what can he do?
He's like, he's not going to read
the comments and he's a smart guy.
He's a very smart guy. But uh,
he took it like a man to be able to go
and do an interview right after you get
knocked out like that. It's very
admirable, but that's who he is.
That's how you get to be a guy
who says good or wrestlers.
A guy like Ben Aspirin who
can handle a loss like that.
The what do you think of
the, I forgot the, I can't,
I can't pronounce the guy's name. Who
beat him? Jorge Mossville Mazda doll.
What he said after the fight,
but he said he would smack him if
he saw him at whole foods. I think,
I think it's just a little
too much. You want I, I can't,
I don't know the history. The
history is rough. Excuse me.
It's like 10 years of them, uh,
given him a hard time of if
Ben asked her and given miles.
But all according to
Mossville lot of talking shit,
which some people think is
friendly in Moundsville street.
Jesus doesn't fuck around. All
right. You want to talk shit.
You want to talk shit just street Jesus.
He will fucking make fun of you after we
flat lines here. And that's what I did.
He flatlined them in five seconds,
made them the fastest Evekeo in UFC
history and then mocked him afterwards and
said he would smack him if he
saw him in whole foods. But see,
we're talking about it. So
Mazda dollars smart. This is a,
this is amazing marketing
ploy, right? I mean, he's,
he's become in one fight the most talked
about fighter in the sport because he
did something in the sport that's been
around for a little bit that nobody's
ever done before. Yeah.
Ben Asker was undefeated,
undefeated and Mazda doll comes out flat
lines like that and talk some pretty
vicious shit after the fact and even
mimicked him laying on the floor,
which looks scary the way he
was out. Yeah. Mazda doll.
We'll say a calls out easy. Conor
McGregor. I want to break his face. Yeah,
that would be, that's a rough fight.
That's a rough fight for Conor Moz Woodall
was a big fellow too. I mean, he's,
he really belongs at one 70
that's where he's fighting.
He fought at one 55 but really tortured
himself to make that weight. All right.
He's a big guy.
You're talking about a guy who knocked
out cowboys Serone knocked out Darren
tail, knocked out Ben Aspirin. I mean,
he's knocking out big welterweights
big Darren tills a big welterweight.
He's big. He's not a guy
coming up from 155 pounds.
He's never making 0050505155 so yeah.
So he's one way class a heavier and he's
really running into like the last few
fights. He's, he's coming into his own.
These are really becoming something
special. He had a real close uh,
decision loss to Wonderboy.
Wish I could remember
how that fight went down.
I D I just think it was a decision,
I don't know if it was a split
decision or you now know this decision,
but I think it was just
wonderful outpointed them.
I don't think there was any
knockdowns or anything Mazda though.
Yeah that was Mossville but Wonderboy
is a particularly difficult guy to fight
and especially for three rounds.
Pedis recently knocked him out but a pet
is just hit him with the perfect punch
and that can happen to
anybody. And Pedis timed it.
And Pedis is a beast as
wild. Yeah. He's a wild man.
He's a fantastic fighter. Like
losing to him it's like, yeah,
you lost to one of the best
fighters ever. And he also like,
he's a guy who dropped Tony
Ferguson. I mean pet is knocked out.
Cowboys Serone pet is knocked out.
Joe Lozan with his crazy head chain.
That is is a monster. This is like, he'll
win one and then lose one. Yeah. Wow.
It's, it's a crazy division
man. It's filled with murderers.
Just murder after murder.
Both divisions 55 and 70 and I think
pedis is probably going to do real good at
70 because he's healthier. You know?
I think he went down to one 45 and it
almost killed him. It was just too much.
Man. He had nothing in the tank.
And then Max Holloway beat him up.
He lost two a, I think he
lost the Charles only rera.
I think so. I might be wrong. He
might've caught Charles Olivera.
Hmm. I don't know.
Pettis has the most legit
crazy look in his eye
pedis one right. Choked him. Banqueting
choke him. That's right. That's right.
I'm confused. He lost to someone else at
one 45 who else did he lose it to at 45
Oh, Barboza was 55 Dustin. Boy,
I don't think that was 55 and he lost
a toe that was 45. He doesn't say what
he lost the Tony, right? Yes. He lost the,
Tony broke his hand and the
fight and he hasn't stopped,
but it was a great fight. Wound up
dropping him. Oh, okay. So Charles Oliver,
Edson Barboza and then Oliveira
think that was thing that was 55.
I think Max Holloway was 45. I
don't know man. I'm not sure though.
And then he went back up to 55 the
other Dustin Pourri a fight that was,
um, that was, he got injured
and that was at 55 catch weight.
That fodder. He missed the weight.
Oh, he missed a fight with Max.
So he's trying to get down to 45. So
featherweight debut was against Olivera.
So he submissions Olivera submitted
ovarian is featherweight debut. Okay.
So he had two fights at that weight and
that weight was torturous for him and he
didn't make it for the
Max Hallway fight. Um,
and then Jim Miller's definitely a 55
pound fight and all the other ones were 55
until he got to Steven Thompson.
And that was the last one. Um,
wonder boy that was uh, that
was at welterweight. Yeah. Yeah.
That was an amazing fight. I mean,
so I think sometimes these guys,
it's just too much,
man. It's just too much.
He beat Michael Cassa says he beat
Cassa and caste is another one.
He was fighting at 55 and
now he moved up to 70. Yeah.
That ended up being a catch weight fight.
He's guessing missed these
fucking guys, man. They're,
they're killing themselves.
That weight cutting.
Imagine if that was the case with
soccer, like before a soccer game,
everybody had like, you had a certain
amount of guaranteed weight on the field.
Imagine like Ian, you know, you
are whatever position it is,
you have to cut down to
130 pounds. You'd be like,
fuck the drain your body in a sauna.
And then everybody weighs in that.
Everybody rehydrates and then the next
day you played as grueling ass game.
That'd be ridiculous. Right?
Fighting is the most tiring thing.
It would totally compromise
the game, wouldn't it?
Some magic football
players had to do that.
Imagine football players only had
like, okay guys, whatever the team is,
it has to weigh 4,000 pounds. That's
it. No more. And so you have to decide,
hey, you know Bob can't cut lower than
to 60 we checked his body fat Joe,
you're going to have to
get down to one 80 Jamie
when we were kids playing football we had
to weigh in and that sort of happened.
We were like yeah cause a,
if you were a certain weight,
like you had to have stripes on your
helmet and it means you could only play
like on the line. You couldn't be carrying
the ball cause you'd be fucked. Nope.
No kids could tackle
you. Fuck them all up.
So there was like definitely a limit.
And I remember I did have to wear the
trash bag and like cut five pounds or try
to, I don't know fucking
know how much I weighed,
but it was so I could be a tight end and
catch the ball. Cause I was a little,
I was like on the border,
dude, that was such so bad for
kids. I had a friend in high school,
my friend Steve and he's all of his
brothers like six one, six, two,
he's like five, six. He never grew.
And there was because all throughout
high school and junior high school,
he was cutting weight and wrestling. Dan,
I guarantee you it had
something to do with it.
Everyone else's family is tall or is and
he was always tired or his dad is not,
he's real dad. Oh No, it was brothers
looked just like, Huh, okay. He uh,
he was always tired. He'd be walking
around the hallways like this. Like uh,
cause he didn't do wrestling
camps. He would do the whole thing.
So he's always wrestling who's
always exhausted. Always.
It's a terrible thing for kids.
The fact they still have kids do that
is fucking madness. It's madness.
People didn't know any better.
My parents didn't even ask me
when I got on the wrestling team,
they didn't have that. You're
not cutting weight, are you?
They didn't even ask me. They had no
idea. Did you just listen to the coach?
Coach tells you to lose
weight. You gotta lose weight.
Fuck so bad for the body. It's
so bad for your brain too,
because dehydrates your brain
and then you're in class.
You're trying to listen in
class and you're fucking,
it's worse than being hung over.
That's true because all they tell us to
do now is drink water and stay hydrated,
and then you're doing something that's,
you can't put anything in your system.
You're just trying to drain it out. It
doesn't affect you mentally. Yeah. Yeah.
When you get dehydrated, your brain
works like shit. Right? Like they say,
that's one of the things that happens
to people in the desert when they start
dying of thirst. They can't think
straight. Right. They don't,
they don't make good decisions. Yeah.
I've been fatigued like in soccer
practice and you're just like,
you'll be wearing an opposing
player shirt and just from fatigue,
I'll just pass it to you just to not
have to have the responsibility of this
ball. You know what I'm saying? For Real,
like fuck it and I'm trying to make team
at the time and I'm like making just
blatant mistakes. I'm just so tired,
man. Yeah. Fatigue makes cowards of men,
Vince Lombardi's lawn. Hey
did did that to me in college.
Where are you falling out?
I'm Greentree at all his stories
at this point in the video.
He said he hadn't had water for like 18
hours and he's still climbing up hill
and needs to find it. Yeah. Great. That's
insane. Well, he had to get rescued.
I don't know if he broke his
arm. I haven't chatted with him,
but he thinks he broke
his arm too. It is a,
if you go to my friend Adam Green
trees, Instagram, Adam. Dot. Green Tree.
He documented this con that he went in
for a thing called the Himalayan tar that
lives in New Zealand and it lives
in these Alpine mountain areas. Oh,
I don't know what's Alpine mountain
dangerous slippery mountain areas. And uh,
he got stuck out there and they had to
get rescued and fell into the frozen
glacier river and was freezing
to death. Had a climate to his,
a sleeping bag soaking wet.
Yeah. Really dangerous.
Fell thought he broke his arm. Yeah.
Was worried that he
might have broke his leg.
Did he pull out his camera and
film half of it too? Probably.
I don't think he filmed much of
it. He felt filmed some of it,
but he was having a really hard time and
then he had to get rescued and he had
to go somewhere where the helicopter
could land so they could winch him and
carry him up and rescue him
and take him to the hospital.
Fucking dangerous shit. There's
a lot of these guys like Adam,
who's a good friend of mine who loves
to go on these like visionquest solo
adventures.
So he'll go to the mountains and camp
out by himself for 28 days and he films
and it puts it up on Instagram. Right.
We're just talking to himself and true
like hunting elk and he's like mountain
areas. And last year that's
his, uh, his campsite.
Last year he had a one on one encounter
with a grizzly bear and he had a pistol
with him and he's documenting him,
trying to hold off this mama grizzly
was standing up in the background.
She made several charges at him and he
didn't even know that the pistol was
jammed. The ammunition was the
wrong size. So the lever like Ci,
when you cock it, it couldn't, it
couldn't fit another bullet in there.
So he had a big dummy gun. He's pointing
a gun to Sunday, even read it man.
So if you pull the trigger,
nothing would have happened.
So then he realized that
that was a problem when he,
I guess he had tried to fire it a to
make sure it does work or something.
So then he had to realize
that he had to put,
he could put one bullet in the
chamber, but he couldn't reload.
He could reload musket style.
Yeah, so he had one bullet,
essentially one bullet,
he the wrong ammo for the pistol and
you only get one shot with one of those
charts. You don't even get one man.
You know when they're running at you,
you are shitting your pants
and you can't believe it.
You're going to miss half the
bullets. If you have 10 bullets,
if you hit it once, you're lucky.
It's madness because you're not going to
shoot when it's 10 feet away from you.
You're going to shoot as it's
running towards you and you, you,
I don't think you're going to be able
to hold that position. It's too crazy.
What is the bear doing when
it's like making charges at him,
but you're not coming at him trying to
get you to get the fuck away from its
babies. Almost always. Almost always
get the fuck away from my babies.
It's almost always a woman,
female bear rather protecting
their code that's there.
They don't fuck around some
asshole that might be a hunter.
He might be hunting bear. You might
want to shoot my baby. Oh yeah.
They don't know. Yeah. You
might just be, you know,
they don't think of humans as a good
thing. Humans are dangerous. Right.
You know, it's not our are fucking
weird. They're predators. Yeah. I'm just,
I'm surprised bears don't attack
humans just more often based on that.
Like how do they distinguish
who's a hunter and who's not.
They don't think of hunters as
being something they should attack.
They think that they should get the fuck
out of there because when they see guns
go off and then a bowl of bullet
hits a bear right next to them,
that bear kind of explodes and screams
and agony and falls to the ground.
They just want to get the fuck out of
there and not have it happen to them.
Right. So if they've seen
that ever in their life,
they've seen a bear gets shot,
which if you're in a place
where bears get hunted,
it's very likely that they have
seen that. They just run away.
They smell people they run, they want
to get the fuck out of their bears.
Look at humans like predators, only
in places where people hunt parents.
The problem is when
people don't hunt bears,
bears have zero fear of humans and
then bears wind up killing people.
This is what you see in Yellowstone
because those bears are grizzly bears and
the only place in America where you can
hunt grizzly bears is in Alaska and in
Alaska.
They have a different attitude and
they're starting to open up grizzly bear
seasons.
I think there was one that we're trying
to do in Wyoming and there might've been
one somewhere else where they were
trying to do, they do it in Canada,
but they recently banned
it in British Columbia,
and the reason why they banned it is not
because the people that live near the
grizzly bears, they're
encouraging it because these,
these things are fairs coming
today and dangerous, right?
It's the people that live in the
cities are the most people like this,
the biggest population center in
British Columbia, in Vancouver, right?
It's all urban, so that's
the giant mass of people.
But the people that live like where
my friend Mike Hockridge lives,
those people don't have a say. And
those are the ones who live with bears,
right?
They have wolves and bears all over
the place up there and the black bears,
which you can hunt, those
are not even dangerous.
I mean they're dangerous but not
dangerous compared to grizzlies.
Grizzlies are fucking dangerous
in those cities making those
decisions from that people,
even conservative people that are animal
lovers and just don't understand what a
bear is. They're not kill.
I mean the idea is that they want to
stop trophy hunting cause you see like
Cecil the lion, that kind of
shit. It's disgusting. And it is.
It is a lot in a lot of ways like wanting
to go and just shoot these things just
to stop them and put them on your walls.
There's a lot of weird
shit to that that I,
I totally understand your
feelings on it. I get it.
But the grizzly bear thing
is a different thing.
There was the people that were raised
on the cartoon and they're like,
stop killing these cartoons.
Yeah. The cartoon version.
Not The animal that they saw growing
up today. I have no idea. Well,
even in Africa,
the exact area where
Cecil the lion was killed,
they had a recently killed 200
lions because they're lions.
Yeah.
Because so many lions had survived
because there was no hunting because they
came back, they came back up.
It's a weird, it's not good.
It's not ideal. The situation's
not ideal cause it's so,
so bizarre and twisted.
The animals survive because
people pay to kill them.
That's what the African wildlife
model in these encaged areas is.
So they have like 10,000 acres or some
shit like that. They put it in fences.
Right, right. And then
inside those fences,
you have zebras and giraffes and all
these different animals and you can come
over there and pay and you can go
and hunt these animals. That's,
that's a lot of the
area. So at this guy who,
that Cecil guy who shot that lion,
he paid like $50,000
to go and hunt a lion.
And there's probably one a
day, two a day, three a day.
So there's hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of dollars of revenue coming in.
This revenue comes in for these
guys that want to kill lions,
and what they do is they use it to
raise more lions and they use it to pay
professional hunting.
These people called professional hunters
are basically game wardens to keep out
poachers and to make sure that
these animals don't get like rhinos,
don't get their horns chopped off and
murdered just just for their horns,
things, elephants for their
tusks, things along those lines.
So they need to hire people to protect
against poaching. Because look,
in Africa, there's a lot of people that,
and especially in these areas where
they have these hunting areas,
these vast rural areas,
people are extremely poor and
they want animals to just to eat,
and they're going to call that
poaching and they have to pee.
So then it gets even squirrely
there, right? It's not,
it's not an ideal situation by
any stretch of the imagination.
But because no hunters were coming in now
because of all the bad press after the
Cecil the lion shit,
they had to kill 200 lions
because [inaudible] cause
that many like got born and
grew up in because they have
a real unnatural situation
over there where they're
breeding these lions and then
they put them in the like some,
every place does it a different way.
And some places are free range where
there's no fence at all. That is true.
There's some places that are like that,
but some places it's all fenced in.
The whole thing's fenced in. It's like
a zoo, like a fake wild fake. It's,
they took the wild and they made it fake.
Just put a fence around the wild and
then they kept introducing food and then
they have lions that they keep in very
specific areas and they feed them and
then they'll transport them to the middle
and then they have the hunter comes
that day and they tell them where the
lion is and the guy goes out there, boom,
shoots the lion. And poses
with the lion. It's perverse.
It's Kinda been a perverse.
On the other hand,
these animals that are in there,
particularly at the antelopes and black
bucks and not knitting now Neil guy and
all these crazy wild
fucking antlered creatures,
they're in greater numbers than
they've ever been. So it's so twisted.
It's like the numbers are so high because
people want to come in and pay to hunt
them. Right? But then the numbers
are high so people can hunt them.
It's not like so that they can keep the
whole wildlife ecology free in Rome.
And look how vibrant Africa is now
that we've stepped in with all these
conservation dollars. Not really. No.
It's fenced in and then people
drive up to a spot, get out, boom,
take a picture to weird.
We fuck up everything.
Great job. It's weird. Great job people.
Yeah, we're the best. I'm reading a,
an explanation of a person that has gone
to this park in Zimbabwe to go see the
lions and they've done this in the past
and they went back more recently and uh,
this is hilarious. Read this thing here.
Then our hose gave us
our safety orientation.
He told us to speak to
the lines in a calm voice,
approached slowly and to
pet them on their backs.
Only then our hosts handed out
skinny sticks to each of us.
He explained that if a lion
approached us in a threatening manner,
we should switch the stick back and
forth in the grass is tracked them
what?
What will I have to eat you?
There's a Jesus Christ that says that
they thought that they were going to go
see like child baby cubs
in a case. Definitely not.
They're like 18 months old almost,
you know, a little bit older.
They're probably short of adolescent
lions. Yeah, like this big,
I saw this video like this a try
bound or what part of Africa,
but like if a cheetah
or like a like a cat,
like hunts down an animal
and kills it like these,
these, these people from this tribe,
like they track the hunt and then once
the animal or the cat kills the food,
then they will scare off the the
cat. I saw them take it and it,
and they have these little sticks. Yeah.
And then the fucking cheat is
or whatever, runaway from them.
And I'm like so
crazy. I saw that. I watched a video of
that month. Someone's Instagram. Yeah.
Well you gotta do what you gotta
do when you're hungry. Yeah.
You take a chance then. I mean,
unless they have a really good weapon,
it's hard to get an antelope. You
got to get fucking close. Right.
But a cheetah can just
chase it down. If I'm a,
you would think it's, it's just crazy
that a human could take a Cheetah's food.
Yeah, it is crazy. Yeah. They do it with
lions too. Yeah, they do. With spears,
they, they, they run up on lines
with spears. I've seen that too.
Like female lions, it's roaring at
people where they drag away their food.
Robin a lion, lion, she
goes back to her, to the,
to the house and husband's like,
where's the food? I got one
robbed. Well,
what we do here in cities is
so recent and so unnatural.
It's not like anything that
anybody else has ever done before.
In terms of like a human beings
up until about 10,000 years ago,
there's never been shit like this.
Supermarkets and stuff like that. Yeah.
All of it. And no interaction at all
with nature. You, our interaction with
nature is reserved to, you know,
squirrels, fucking pigeons and shit.
Birds having a dog. Even
fucking pigeons are weird.
They're brought over here as
food now. They were. Yeah,
and they're everywhere that you
could see. You could eat pigeons.
They're delicious.
Apparently. I never had one.
I don't think a lot of
people like they look at,
they just don't look at pigeons
as food. No. Yeah. Most people,
yeah. 99% of they have pigeon seasons.
Actually. Maybe they don't have a season.
Pigeons might be like wild
pigs where they're like a,
they're considered a invasive species.
They're not supposed to be here.
They're not from here. They
brought them over here for squad.
You ever heard like squad
when people meet squad? Nah.
The squad was like a fancy word
for a young pigeon. It's like lamb.
Lamb is a fancy word for a young
sheep. How does a pigeon taste you?
Had it never had. Oh I never had
it. No, I had squirrel. How's that?
Um, is if someone told me it was chicken,
I would believe him. Oh for real?
Yeah. I taste a lot like that. Which
is the most cliche shit to say ever.
It tastes hot chicken. How do
you know if you catch a squirrel?
If it's rapid on that? If you
cook it, you don't catch anything?
That's a weird question.
That's a good question.
I don't know the answer to that.
Maybe rabies would die at a
certain temperature. Right?
Squirrels are not a well ground squirrels.
I was going to say squirrels are not
um, omnivores. They're herbivores.
But ground squirrels.
I'm pretty sure eat meat cause I've
seen videos of ground squirrels eating a
mouse. Right? Oh Dan
fucked up. It seems wrong.
Anything either mouse is wrong.
Like when you feed a mouse to
a snake or some shit like that?
Well it's even more wrong cause
it's holding in his hands.
Dogs and cats that are
currently vaccinated and
kept under observation for 45
days. Oh, what if it, oh, can you
get rabies from eating squirrel.
Small mammals such as squirrels, rats,
mice Hampshire's getting pigs, durables,
chipmunks,
rabbits and hares are almost never found
to be infected with rabies and have not
been known to cause rabies amongst
humans in the United States. Okay,
so rats can't give you rabies.
That's interesting. Rat eating.
It's about to go up. I saw videos.
You could y'all biting the head
off of a rat. It's fucking nasty.
What was biting the head
of a rock guy? A Guy,
man where an Asian man out in the whole
fucking thing at like right off an
episode of fear factor stuff.
It was raw. It's funny.
I think it was dead and he didn't see
it move him before, but no, it's funny,
you wouldn't have been able to do fear
factor in certain countries there.
It'd be like, where's the fear, right?
Like where's the, what we eat that.
I've got a lot of friends
that are Filipinos.
Especially back in when I was doing fear
fights because I was playing a lot of
pool. Some of the best pool players
are Filipinos. It's huge. And Pool,
um, with pool rather. But they were
laughing at me because they serve Balut.
They're like, we love Balut
allude is this weird duck embryo.
It's like a delicacy.
The sort of people on fear factor were
terrified of it and these people are
like, no, we pay for that.
We like it. Yeah, it's great.
I look at those people wasting the Balut
or whatever it is. They eat a beacon.
Everything. Man Balut is weird.
It's an embryo. It's like a little,
it's like a little baby
duck. It's very strange.
I wonder if you'd even be able
to do fear factor today. I mean,
I know ludicrous is still doing it,
but they're doing a different
kind of version of it. Right?
Have you watched one of those
episodes just to check it out now? No.
That's like watching your ex
girlfriend get banged. That's,
you really want to see bang to badly.
What'd you want us to watch her get
banged badly. See I was better than,
so it's weird to take over someone's Gig
because if someone did it for so long
and they had a certain style,
how they did it, please pimp my,
my fear factor. Ludicrous.
Right. When like when, um,
who was, who did pimp my ride there
was a, what's his name? [inaudible].
Yeah. Whatever happened to that dude.
I think he's still acting and doing
stuff. Yeah. He was the pimp. My ride guy.
That was a huge show. How the
fuck did that show go away?
I know what that feels like. Yeah. It
feels like I could just keep going. Yeah.
Yeah. That's like one of them of pawnshop
shows they never have to end. Yeah.
Just keep punting. Just, yeah. Do it in
different countries. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Why? Why would they, and pip
maybe exhibit was like done.
I can't deal with these
people in their cars.
Start making all those other shows.
There's tons of car shows now and all
those other channels. Pimping Shit. Yeah,
but that's the best name. Oh yeah.
Pimp my ride. That's the best name.
When you say it's the best, most of
those are undrivable like yeah, I've,
there's been a lot of like reddit things
where people were like asking for like
a, have you ever been
on pimp my ride? Look,
tell us about your experience or whatever.
And like they did so much shit to
those cars that would be like, hey,
by the way, when this is over,
go ahead and take half of that shit out
so you can legally drive it down the
fucking freeway if you
would have it every time.
But some of the times they had to do that.
If you has one five cars now
from pimp my ride, it'd be huge.
Collector's item should be like worth
a lot of money if you still kept it.
I think they started bringing it back.
But yeah, let me see. I use an article.
What really happened in
the cars from pimp my ride?
Um,
I remember definitely remember a couple
of the guys said that they had to stay
in contact with a few of the like, uh,
in house mechanics because they had
to keep getting something fixed.
I believe that like they had to constantly
drive back to Hollywood or wherever
the fuck it was. Right. That makes
sense. I'm trying to find, well, a lot of
the shows like, um, my buddy bud,
who's been on the podcast before,
he used to have that show,
uh, fuck, what was it called?
What was that show where they would
steal someone's car and rebuild it?
It would make them think
their, their car was stolen.
I can't remember his fucking show.
God it, it was chip Foose, chip Foose,
uh, would redesign their car and they
would get this fucking amazing car.
What the fuck was the
name of that show? But a
bud Brotzmann he used
to have the show rides.
That was a show where they built my
1970 Barracuda and then overhauling
overhauling. That's it. All right.
That's it. Shout out to bud and Adrian,
who is the host, um, they, uh,
would take a car and they'd do it in
like a really short amount of time.
And then after it was over, they
would have to like tighten it all up.
And when they do a build a car,
they have a shakedown period where like
they drive it for a few hundred miles to
make sure there's nothing goes
wrong, everything's working right.
It's like this period of time to make
sure that everything's dialed in.
They don't get a chance to
do that in a week. Right.
So that's probably what
they're talking about.
Yeah. The sub pimp, my ride thing,
I'm reading through it like some of the
contestants said they had to dumb up
like they had to completely just play the
game of this as a TV show. Exaggerate.
Let's dump a bunch of cigarette butts in
your car to make it look shittier than
it is. Hey, when we show it to you,
please be fucking happy when you see this.
We can have a good like reaction for
TV kind of thing. That's disappointing.
Yeah. God Damn it. Pimp my ride. How
dare you. That's every show though. Yeah.
That's every show. Any
like, like Haitch GTV show.
Oh yeah. Well I just hoarders. Yeah.
We're going to have to hoard your place
up even more probably, right? Yeah.
Like, like preppers. Those people
prep. I make them extra crazy.
I haven't seen purpose. Was that about
people were prepping for the apocalypse?
Oh yeah. Listen,
we know you're crazy, but we're gonna
make you look even crazier. Even down.
Even crazier. Yeah. Oh
Man. Or intervention.
You know what's interesting to me,
it's typically right wing people who uh,
are in favor of like,
if you think about, uh,
anytime someone passes a law
that's bad for the environment,
right? If they want to drill in Alaska,
if they want to do something overseas,
it's usually, I mean it's
might be generalizing,
but usually thought to be
a right wing thing, right?
It's like more concerned for business
than concern for the environment. Right.
People that are on the left of the people
that are always like the tree huggers,
those are the environmental.
So the people that are like
radical environmentalist,
you would almost always think of
as being people on the left, right?
But the people that are prepping for
shit going south are almost always on the
right. The right wing people
are the ones who are prepping.
The world's going to come to an end.
So those are the ones that
carrying bullets and they
fucking digging tunnels in
their backyard. I know what you're doing.
You know you're destroying the earth
by digging for oil and all that shit.
But it's not them. It's usually the
big wigs, right? Right. The big,
but they're voting and they're in favor
of all those decisions that the big
wigs, yes. Make inadvertently because
the big wigs have themselves to Jesus.
That's what they did. That's what
the wise thing they did to good fat,
old fashioned family values. Jesus.
They figured a way to connect it to a
thing that everybody can argue against.
The connected right wing ideology with
God and left wing with a portion killing
babies. Right. The line in
the sand has been drawn, Ian,
if you're prepping for the
end of the world, right.
You got to secretly be hoping
for the end of the world.
Maybe a little bit of end
because you try your shit. Yeah.
Just to try your shit and to
say I wasn't crazy. Right.
And wasting my time. So you gotta kind
of be rooting for the end of the world.
Like you don't want to, you know,
do all that shit in vain. Right.
You know what I mean? So that's kind of
a weird nest to those type of people.
That's a good point. You know what I mean?
Like you started doing comedy and there's
people like you're never gonna make
it.
You want to make it to be like you are
wrong and to just the relief of knowing
you are right. Well, I think
that's a problem with cops.
I think cops won't shoot people.
Sometimes they have a gun
and they almost want someone
to do something fucked up
so they could shoot him.
Not every cop, not every,
not every cop, right?
But there are certain people
that should not be cops. Right.
Those people that become cops. And
it does happen. And we all know, and,
and I'm on 100% supporter of law
enforcement, but even law enforcement,
they know it. They don't want to be
surrounded by some weak fuck. Who's, uh,
who's also a cop, wants to shoot people.
There's people out there that wanna
shoot people and you give them a gun.
If you give someone a hammer,
everything looks like a nail.
That's amazing. Yeah.
I remember the video and this was
a white cop shooting a white guy,
the Arizona one, I think it was in a
hotel on the hall. Yeah. And that guy,
he's like, how did he become a cop?
How does he not go to jail? Yes.
They let him off the hook for that one.
They always kind of let them off the hook.
They'll give me a slap on the wrist
and just get them out of there.
And the instructions,
he was given this guy,
I was telling him to keep your hands away
from your waist because his pants were
falling down his pants. And the guy
was saying that to him too. Yeah.
And he's just crying and crawling
towards them like, Hey, I was listening.
The guy reaches because his pants fell
down and grabs a hold of his pants to
pull him up. Like I fills
his backup with bullets. Him,
shoots him in the back on the floor
crawling because guys have no threat.
Was yelling, making the
situation even more chaotic.
He's also telling the guy to do
something. Why are you making a move?
Just tell him to lie down.
Put his hands behind his back.
You handcuff him and then now he was
ordering the guy to crawl towards him.
Yeah. It doesn't even make sense. Did
you see this video earlier this week?
This was from July 1st yes. Yeah.
The guys are crazy. This is crazy.
This is what's called suicide by cop.
This guy was coming towards this cop
screaming with a knife and the cop was
begging him to please stop. Please stop.
This is after they already shot up Jamie,
but meanwhile he wants up tackle
in this fucking, this is what's
crazy.
This guy's already been shot and he
turns on this cop and tackles him right
here. Tackles him. Look at this.
The guys fill with bullets and
the guy's reaching for his gun.
He gets his back and he takes him
down and then this does not get,
in my opinion, he doesn't have the knife
anymore, does he? Yeah. I don't know.
I can't tell what if it's in his hand
right there. It's hard to see. Did you see
video of the black cop walking
towards the guy with the machete?
Yes, I did see that and it just like
walked right into it and just parried and
flipped him over. Yeah, it was crazy.
That is crazy. I saw another one
that Eddie Bravo sent me of a,
was not a cop one, but two dudes
were having a conversation.
That's God's got his hand behind the back
and he pulls a knife out of his pocket
and the guy doesn't even see and he just
in the middle of the conversation just
sticks him in the stomach
and the guy's standing there.
He moves back and he's like holding
his stomach. You can't believe it.
Then the guy comes towards him again,
follows him and the guy who got
stabbed winds up knocking the dude out.
The guy's coming towards him with the
knife again saying, I'll stab you again.
The guy hits him with a left hook and
rocks him and then hits him with the right
hand and knocks him out. And he's
a regular dudes, regular dudes.
It looks like regular dudes, but the
dude who got stabbed knew how to fight.
Luckily for him, but he still
might die in the stomach.
That is fucking very
dangerous, man. Very dangerous.
You know, what are we talking
about? What are you doing?
Kind of find the video like I
getting stabbed. Let's not so much.
There's just so much. There's
so much to just freak you out.
Yeah. I don't, I don't even look at some
of the bad stuff anymore. A lot of it.
Yeah. Like, like I saw at the beginning
of that video when it came out,
like last week, I'm like, I ain't watching
this. I was like, turn it off. Yeah.
You can't watch that. Yeah.
There's so many videos.
You'll get convinced that that's
happening everywhere in the world.
24 hours a day. It will fuck your
head up. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, yeah.
God Damn it. It's easy
to get freaked out. Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of
frequent bull shit out there.
There is.
This is a good spot as I need
to talk about this. Um, we,
I want to make sure that I clarify
something because there was some,
there was an operation.
This is a guy who was a
billionaire diamond guy who uh,
wound up getting a dick enlargement
operation and he died because of the
anesthesia and it was in another
country and we pulled out, we, we,
we were saying somehow or another it
got connected to this company that does
that in the United States. It had
nothing phenomena for pneuma. Yeah.
The article I had said like he was getting
a similar surgery and that this one,
the one only the [inaudible] only
happens in the u s but he was getting
something done in Europe. So
it was like different, well,
they reached out to me to explain, first
of all, the guy died from anesthesia.
You can get and you could die from
anesthesia from any operation.
Had nothing to do with the, the
penis enlargement operation to use.
The more correct
term, dick enlargement a,
but he didn't die from that.
And that's just as safe as a getting
your nose fixed or getting your knee
meniscus operated on. Right.
It's just the [inaudible].
Any surgery where you have a anesthesia
carries a certain amount of risk,
but apparently this dick thing works.
They actually can grow your Dick Beggar.
Now you have a risk in your
life. Well it'll work well.
You're risking your life if
you go to the dentist. Yeah.
Once you wonder like anytime you get
put under, right. If you, if you,
if anything you're doing with anesthesia,
there's a very small chance
that something could go wrong.
But I had nothing to do
with this Dick Operation,
so I just wanted to make sure that
people know that if you look this up,
I don't want anything, any,
a incorrect assumptions to be out there
and I carry no ill will towards this.
These people that make this
and apparently it works.
So I just want everybody to know that
it's carry no ill will towards this
company that makes Dick's
bigger. Apparently. It actually,
it's a weird thing, right?
Like A, for a man to do that.
There's certain taboos that are involved
in even a admitting that you have an
issue like a little dick
as a weird thing, right?
Because it's one of the rare things that's
unfortunate that you can make fun of,
right? Like you can't make
fun of a little person, right?
Like if you make fun of a
person who is a, you know,
you're not supposed to call the images,
right? So let's call them little people.
They make fun of a person who's
a dwarf or a little person.
You're a cruel person, right? But if you
make fun of a guy with a little Dick,
like how he deserves it or some shit,
that's a weird thing that
women are allowed to do.
Like you're allowed to make fun of
dudes having little decks. We should,
there should be something
in the same vein. Yes.
To protect little girls. What
equal for them from cruelty,
but because if you have a little
pussy, that's fantastic. Yeah.
Everybody's excited about that.
It's not crazy weird situation,
but a big Dick is a sign of a reality.
All right? So we salute you per new ma.
That's the name of the company.
We salute you for helping men.
I achieve larger decks and I almost
died from anesthesia one time.
I thought you were going to say from a
different lifetime what happened when I
was like a teenager. And here's the irony.
I was going in for an operation
that you're supposed to
go in in the morning and
leave in the afternoon. Oh,
it's just a quick thing.
And then it was literally for
a circumcision. I was like,
you are getting a circumcision.
Yeah. What were you doing?
I just had sex with this girl.
Like I was a kid like seven,
like say 18 and uh,
and somehow I'd pull the
skin of my dick back.
Ah,
couldn't get it back to clean it and I
couldn't get the skin back right over to
then I spent like an entire night with
like a roar boner with no skin covering
it. So I went to the doctor Dan,
he got it back over and he said
you should get a circumcision.
So one time operation is going and you
don't have to worry about this shit
happening again. But it only
happened once, right? Yeah.
But well you were furiously
beaten off though, right? No, no,
no. I just, I pulled the skin back
to clean it. Yeah. Yeah. Officer.
I was cleaning that gun when it shot
my neighbor. No, it's clean. It,
it was, there was shit under there. Yeah.
So then I went in and they gave me the
anesthesia and then when I woke up there
was like a hose down my throat and people
are frantic around me and it was like
nighttime. It was way past the time I was
supposed to come back, come to and uh,
the anesthesia gave me pneumonia.
I ended up spending like two or one and
a half to two weeks in the hospital and
the first few days was in intensive
care. Oh yeah. Wow. It was anesthesia.
I did not like wake up. Holy Shit. Yeah.
You almost died getting your
Dick operated on. Yeah. Just,
I was almost that guy then.
But for the most part, listen,
you talking to someone who's had a bunch
of surgeries? I've had my nose fixed.
I've had my arm broken, my hands.
I've had my knees operated on three
times. I've had three knee surgeries.
I've been put under quite a
few times. It's mostly safe.
It's really about the anesthesiologist.
Hey Jamie, just somebody at the door,
try it. Try and figure out,
okay. Why is he doing that?
Wandered rallies. He's got a plan.
I have no idea. He's a chair.
They must be hanging out up there
today. People Weird man. He never know.
You know when you'd get an
Uber, do you know that they,
how much background do they do on an Uber?
So I was trying to explain to when
you're asking me the other day,
I was like to get the like approval
on your app to be like, yes,
this car can drive. Uber is one
thing. But once you have that,
anybody you know can be behind that they
don't like scan your face when you're
in the car every time or anything
like that. It's just, yeah,
I got the Uber Bro. Use it. You
know? So if you and I got an Uber,
like I could drive around and pretend
I'm you, you could get caught. Sure.
But like people definitely do that a
hundred but how many people get caught
driving? No, not fucking
none. Yeah, right, right.
Whoever saw that comment, rideshare.
Remember when you were a kid and there
was kid taxis, whoever thought, man,
I could have my own taxi. These to
have a shit called Gypsy taxis. Right.
And they would arrest those
people in New York? Yes. Yeah.
They would arrest them for
trying to do the Uber thing.
Why don't they get an Uber? Why would
they be a gypsy cab? Five bucks.
This is before that.
It was a year that I lived in New York
that some insane number of gypsy cab
drivers got murdered.
Insane. Oh, for real.
It was something like 40
plus in a year got murdered.
So it was almost one a week. They
were killing gypsy cab drivers.
They would rob them and kill
them. Did they have a, that guy,
I don't know if it was
just one tiles, people.
They were there were just deciding
that these gypsy cab drivers,
I think this was, you know,
boy we're talking like probably like
1990s, 1992 or some shit like that.
Like there was no, uh, there
was no internet and there was,
I don't know, people were paying
ever with credit cards, no cash.
It was all cash. So if
you're a gypsy cab driver,
they saw you as being someone who had a,
a wad of cash on you and then you can't
report it to the police cause you're a
gypsy cab driver. So you
shouldn't even be doing it. Yeah.
But they would just kill him.
But if you're a criminal, yeah,
it's a great crime.
Yeah. It's a smart crime.
Like I'm going to rob somebody
that shouldn't be doing
what they're doing for a
living, so they can't really report them.
Report to the police that
I'm robbing you. Yeah.
But there was shoot them and kill them.
The thing is they would just shoot
him in the head and it should've been,
it's like they would be considered
like maybe these people were illegals.
Maybe these people didn't
have a lot of documentation.
Maybe when they killed them it would be
a dead end because they wouldn't know
what to do. Maybe they
were here by themselves.
Maybe they figured the
cops don't care about.
They would definitely figure the
cops don't care and you know,
because it's cash and because it's
not, it's there's no meter. Right.
So this is like, there's no
record of everything. Right.
How many did you find it in a way that
quickly just Google it. There was one,
I found a story from New York Times 1983
there's a weekend where 11 people were
murdered,
but the store just has a story of one
guy that was found in the front seat of a
gypsy cab murdered. Could have
been a shot. Could've been ice.
It was the 1990s it was the
1990s it was definitely why,
why we moved there.
I think I moved to New York in 91 I think
I lived there from 91 I lived back and
forth in 92 which a story from 1990
a sixth cabeus land in the Bronx,
but it's New York Times. It was just
paypal thing. Yeah. One was killed.
Yeah. I think there was a,
there was a long stretch where it
started to become a big deal, but it's,
I mean if there was 40 Wall
Street guys murdered murders,
Italian two nineties originated
the creation of pirate tax,
kind of the article about it.
It's 19 180 drivers since 1990 180 drivers
have lost their lives while on duty
in the streets, which averages more
than two per month. Wow. That's crazy.
I don't know if that's regular kid.
I don't know. I don't know either.
It might just be cab drivers, but um,
you know, because Gypsy cab drivers,
how do you prove that guy
was a gypsy cab driver?
You just got a dead guy in a car with a
bullet in the back of the head and then
you have to ask his friends. Was this
Guy Gypsy cab driving? Maybe it was,
it was a certain style of car too because
so that passengers could identify it
as it just a cap so that they could
take it and it's like if you're taking a
gypsy cab, you have limited amount of
money and you don't want to pay a cab,
but you want to get to where you're going
have to be identifiable. Here it is.
Cabbies risk death. Uh,
daily in New York jungle under siege crime
hours are long and the mortality rate
high so far this year,
32 taxi drivers had been killed by
armed robbers posing as customers. Yeah.
And I think that's just regular taxi
drivers. Yeah. That's a rough Gig, man.
Yeah. Dope. When we
were living in New York,
imagine if just now you go there,
it's just Uber's everywhere.
Everybody's [inaudible].
Everybody's just using their phones,
standing out like the comedy stores become
a fucking disaster trying to get into
the parking lot. That's a
pain in the ass and age.
Just pull up and block the
driveway. They don't give a fucking,
no one stops them and they're just
going in there left and right,
but just blocking everything, dropping
people off, picking people up.
It's never ending. You can
never get in there. It's weird.
It's like a new thing that no one saw
coming. What could be that like let's,
let's play Gary v here. What's next?
What book? What could, what could we get?
Oh, on the front lines of, for
something like that scooter stuff.
It's crazy. There's like
a one year pilot program,
I think they're calling
it for Los Angeles County.
That's why they're more
and more have popped up.
I think they're just sort of saying,
fate, we're going to do a year,
figure it out.
No one is going to be like taken down
for doing this for like they were trying
and Santa Monica to get
rid of them for a minute,
like the bird scooters and whatnot.
They've ramped it up completely.
There's all sorts of electronic
bikes now. There's at least,
I want to say six or seven different
companies just in Hollywood where I live.
They're just everywhere,
laying all over the sidewalks.
But that's sort of what we're trying
to figure out is how do you leave them
around? Where are you going to
leave them? Is it successful?
I don't know how much taxes
they're paying and how,
like how much money the
city gets brought in. But
yeah I don't mind them but it's just
dangerous walking cause I was walking down
the street one day and I
was about to just, you know,
you just walk in but you just change a
stride a little bit to go to the right
and I almost got hit by one and it
was coming fast and I'm like this the
sidewalk, you know what I mean?
Like you could be serious ass
Manila is that you're supposed
to be on the street with those.
It says do not ride this on the sidewalk,
but it is 100% not safe to be on the
streets of La on those cause people are
getting run over and healthy.
I don't know if anybody's died,
but like downtown La, somebody
driving 50 miles an hour,
ran over someone on a
sidewalk or on a scooter.
Like why the fuck you driving
so fast downtown also?
Well, this people that are crazy
hit and runs happen anyway.
They happen all over the place and
then there's assholes. You know?
People are gonna shoot. Cab drivers are
going to run over scooter drivers. Yeah.
[inaudible] everywhere though.
It's weird to see them and they've started
a band them in certain places. Right.
Some neighborhoods have
tried like West Hollywood.
You kinda can't like them anywhere.
But I think there's cities,
the West Hollywood city. Yeah.
But I mean outside of California,
I mean other cities have just said
no more. Yeah. You Know Vegas,
you can't no fucking way because you have
them Vegas. Most drunk people, right?
Yeah. Oh my God. Drunk people
on scooters. If he was drunk,
drunk people on scooters and drunk people
driving while you were on a scooter.
Yeah. Let's fuck plus
weed now. Weed. Yeah.
How good was Vegas? It was a
good time. It was just fun.
He just had me thinking about what could
be next door. Yeah. What could be next?
Like if we didn't see scooters
coming, we didn't see Uber coming.
What would be the next? What do we,
what do we need? What do we need?
We need protection from the ocean. The
ocean's going to rise up and take us.
That's good. We're melting the
ice caps. It's going to fucking,
we're going to have to
move to Tucson boats.
They're making more subways
here right now. Yeah.
They're going to fill up
with water. What a good name.
I have one in Beverly Hills.
There's going to be canals, canals.
We'll use those for the
toilet. Your 20, 90. Yeah.
We're going to throw our shit down
those tubes. Like I wonder, man,
there were some shit that I was reading
today about the ice caps melting at an
accelerated rate. It's always,
it's never good news. Whenever the,
it's like ice cap melting news.
Like, Hey, and we just found out, uh,
we actually have more ice than we
thought. We're good. All right.
Don't worry about it. What does
that mean? Vegas can get water now?
No Vegas gets their water figured.
They figured out there's so much
money in Vegas, they just steal it.
What do they get it from a
hole in the ground. No ideas.
Is there a well out there?
All I know that got good water pressure
in every hotel I've ever been in.
It's wonderful. Look, that's a human
ingenuity. They build it more shit. Yeah.
And if the uh, ice cabs do melt,
it'll just bring it closer to Vegas.
Vegas or use it. Yeah. The water
will be like real close. Yeah.
I mean we just move inside to the middle.
It's like this is what people
have been doing forever.
This idea that you're supposed to be
able to keep your fucking house on the
water in Santa Monica
sitting crazy, you know?
Yeah. You build a house where the beach
is, your front yard is so nuts distinct.
Those cliffs were always there.
This shit was different decades before.
So keep on thinking it's going to
be like that all the time. Yeah.
If you buy like a seaside house in like
Marina del Ray or someone really nice,
you're making a gamble like over the next,
I'm only going to be alive for
40 more years over those years.
I'm going to let's, let's hope that
this water stays over there. Exactly.
Stays put as hope Mother Nature
does what I want it to do.
Yeah. I just,
I'm going to spend $7 million on this
fucking house with literally no backyard.
It's just ocean and I'm just
going to hope it stays like this.
I just can't wait till my credit becomes
beach front property and then I could
sell it.
I've rented space at a beach house a
couple of years ago when I'm my kitchen.
I was getting my kitchen fixed and we
rented this house in Malibu on the water.
It was beautiful man. You would
wake up, you eat breakfast, damn.
Just be sitting there staring out over
the water and the water would literally
come almost underneath the balcony.
So it looked like you were sitting in
water like you were floating and while we
were on a boat, I was like, wow,
this is so beautiful. It's so,
it makes you feel so good. Yeah. Does
being by the ocean, but what a gamble.
Yeah. Even though it's the best,
like you sound like that's the
ultimate infinity pool. Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah. I don't mind.
Like la Jolla, you have the condo
right by the beach and, and,
and you go to sleep at night. You
can hear the ocean, you wake up.
But then I'd be like, what if is this
is the night, this is the night where,
you know what I'm saying? Yeah.
Just taste the building down and
rushes it out to the mountains.
Let me know this happen so
many times in history. Yeah.
All it takes is a earthquake
or an asteroid hits the ocean.
Oh yeah, yeah. Oh my God.
If an asteroid hit the ocean and
we wouldn't even be safe here,
we wouldn't be safe. We'd probably
wouldn't be safe in Arizona.
It would go deep in Arizona.
Asteroid hit the fucking ocean
just outside of Malibu. Boom.
Just a big one. Everybody
in the Midwest be laughing.
They'd be laughing our asses off. We had
the best property all the time. Yeah,
so we had a duck. Hurricanes,
they have the scariest shit.
I think a tornadoes are
the scariest shit. Yeah.
Those things are so random and they
happen every year. Right? Every year.
It's not like earthquakes happen
every year or hurricane you can track,
you know it's coming. You can prepare.
You could just leave a tornado.
It's just like, did you show up?
Hey Man, I'm here. Yeah. Yeah.
That's the scariest. Yeah,
but that's just something that
people deal with when they, you see,
they wipe out entire
towns, they wipe, they,
they took towns off the map.
I feel like they just always
aim for the small towns. Why?
I think it has to do with
the, with agriculture,
if I'm right,
I think it has to do with like flat
areas and the type of weather that they
have.
And I don't think they'd take place in
areas where there's a lot of trees and
forests. Is that true?
It's more like they don't really happen
in cities because the heat structure and
that creates like a,
where the pressure of air pressure starts
cause it's a caught cold air pressure
system that kind of starts swirling
because of the artificial concrete. Yeah.
All those creates tornadoes
almost protect the bulb.
It does happen in cities from time
to time or like on the outskirts.
But like it's very rare to see
when roll through a downtown.
But does one ever go through
like Colorado on the mountain?
Look in one up right here. That's
why as you were saying trees,
I got video of one, like just ripping
trees up in Texas, so like mm.
But it does mostly the Hash
for sure. I'm flatland. Yeah.
Yeah. Well Texas, uh, Texas
is a lot of crazy wind.
It's so close to Oklahoma.
Oklahoma's like tornado alley.
So you were around there. There was
one that was on t v though. That
was mad.
It was hitting this area where they had
these oil trucks and it was carrying the
semi trucks in the air. I don't know
if there were oil trucks there. Semis,
like can't like, you know,
like a 16 wheeler like fucking
sure hugging like that.
It was flying in a circle in the
sky. Like a fucking newspaper. Yeah.
News. A page from a newspaper
gets caught in the wind.
So I was flying around this,
this fucking tornado was
carrying trucks like that
in this video. This is a Missouri
earlier this year. Hmm. I don't see,
I don't see any evidence. That's
fair. Honestly. New stuff. Okay. Yeah,
but there's a video of the, that's
it right there. That's the video.
This is a video where you see, look
at this, why you see the trucks.
As they get closer,
you can see inside the fucking thing
that is a truck flying in a circle.
If this is the same video.
Sorry, I don't know if that's it.
No, that's, that's the
seminar after lands. I mean,
that might not have even been it,
but it was one where it was probably
so many fucking tornado videos,
but it was one where these trucks were
literally flying around in a circle like
it was carrying this gigantic semi and
just floating it in the air like a paper
airplane. Was it from twists or
though, was it some fake footage? No,
it was real. It was real. Some news
footage from television. He was like,
then it's hard to catch that because
all of these are just already on the
ground. Yeah, no, it was in it from a
distance. There was some news footage.
Anyway, just fucking rambling.
Speaking around, but Ian Ned,
what is that? Somebody
special? When's it coming out?
A Friday at midnight on
comedy central. Oh Shit.
Why did you decide to do it in that
style? It's kind of interesting.
He did it like a Ted talk because
there's so many specials out there.
And I get to do my material
when I do it that way,
but I had a little twist and an extra
layer to it that'll make people be more
interested in it than if I was just
going to do like just a regular stand up.
That's why you clever bastard
once in a while I got an idea.
You know what I'm saying?
And you got the microphone,
a regular microphone just sitting on
the stool in case you change your mind.
Well, the last bit I use the Mike
[inaudible] noticed that. Yeah. Good.
Yeah. The last bit I do with the
Mike. What is in your hand? Uh,
the clicker because,
because some of the topics
put on the screen, like,
just like a tech talk he
taught you click the thing,
that picture represents what
you're talking about and
then you keep on going. I,
I've seen people do that
before, um, with, uh, with,
with Ted talks and I've always thought
that'd be a good thing with comp. Yeah.
Because like even when you look at
your standup, you take on a topic,
you dissect it and you give people
an alternate view of that topic,
just like a tech tone and then you move
on to the next one. So like comics,
like you and me and other people,
it's a perfect format for our standup.
Yeah. Are you doing that when you do,
when you headline we do headline Gig. Nah,
maybe you should maybe I about
doing that. Yeah, I did. Yeah,
I did thought about it at one point
in time, but I'm too lazy. Yeah. Yeah.
Like I don't have merits or
anything so I don't bring it merge.
I don't want to have to make sure they
have a screen on transport one and all
that shit. Then that strategy,
it gets cumbersome. Well,
I heard that Kevin Hart at one
point in time had pyrotechnics,
like he would hit a punchline but
20 flips off flames that shoot through
this guy and arenas and I'm like, man,
that's when that's you add to the
standup, right. It's like props,
but way better. Right? Like, I
feel like props are the rare,
one of the rare things where you can't
do them anymore cause Cara top owns that.
Whereas when I was a kid, man,
there was prop comedians. Yeah,
there was a lot of them. Right.
Jamie, you don't know about anything.
I just remember a lot of ventriloquists
and some people that were doing little
prop things, but yet no one
really had that truck full of,
it'd be the comic that show up to
the mic with a briefcase. Yeah.
And then afterwards he has to gather
his stuff. Like a stripper. Yeah,
they have to his duffle bag
have everything in there. Yeah.
It was a guy that was a,
he was really funny man.
A guy in Boston that used to do
that. Fuck, I'm blanking on his name,
but he had glasses and he had
a real similar kind of act,
but it was kind of like science based.
He had a bunch of weird shit that he
would show Alex Zerbe. Nope. Okay. No,
it was a long time ago. You ever
seen chips? Cooney chips, Cooney.
I've heard the name. Yeah,
he, he had props. But he,
he was a fake magician really.
So like I remember the name of that
Tupperware that's expanded. Yeah.
Like that was one of his friends was
just all was, but he was funny, like,
you know, and then pull
it out. That's the trick.
And this keep going onto
the next goofy thing.
There was a guy named Lenny
Schulz and he, uh, he remember,
remember crazy Lenny. Yeah. He
had a bunch of problems. Yeah.
I watched a Steve Burns documentary on
the amazing Jonathan that he's just put
out. It was really good, wasn't it?
Yeah. I liked as a younger kid, I love,
I liked him just because of
a zany crazy shit he did.
But watching the documentary
was awesome. So what is it? Yes.
Shout out to Steve Burn. What does it
basically about? Like he lived in excess,
right?
It's definitely about that sort of like
his rise and maybe I would say fall,
but then sort of how he came back and
was died. There's a lot of to about this.
A Fan that became his manager and sorta
he helped him and guided him along and
apprenticed him a little bit and just
about the relationship and one footage
together. It was just interesting.
It's an interesting guy. Wow.
Yeah. Those guys from the
fucking eighties went hard, man.
That was the Kinison era. You know, if
you wanted to be a wild man, you haven't
figured out how to snort coke
on stage. He's just like fall,
make a joke about it. It was
supposed to be fake coke,
but he's really saying I'm really doing
it like a lot. So he made a bit. Yeah.
Huh. That was not a prop.
That's real shit. Yo.
I bet people have done a lot
of weasley shit like that.
Like just put something into their act.
They'll pull something off, you know,
like I would think like it's a,
one of the core things about comedy is
also one of the weird things that it's so
open ended like the club, just
like you get booked to the
Bray Improv. Right, right.
You show up like what's up being, how
are you man, you know, and you're like,
Hey, this is my opening act. They,
they shake hands, everybody's cool.
They don't even ask you what
you're going to talk about. Right.
They got everybody sitting there.
People paid money, they've sold tickets,
they sold drinks,
and they have not a clue as to what
you're going to discuss and you just go up
there and say whatever the fuck you want.
America love it. Crazy. Yeah.
What a weird way to make a living and
then you'd do the same thing for like a TV
show or something. You have to
type it out. Yeah, send it to them.
They've got to look at it. That's a
beautiful thing to do with Netflix.
Netflix didn't say shit. They
just said, hey, we want to do,
we want to do a special with you. I said,
great. All right, let's do it. I said,
okay, let's
do it. It was that easy. We did it and
they said, okay, great. You did it.
We like it. We'll put it up. Boom.
I had to send comedy central
or a proof of concept,
like I got to shoot the
set, like in a small club,
sent it to them and they're
like, all right, okay. Oh yeah.
Well the good news is
they approved, right.
It's on TV and a special
is always in my opinion,
really just an advertisement to get
people to come see you. Exactly right.
So I'm glad the advertisements out. Oh
yeah. Cause me to, I've said it before.
I'll say it again. Why are you here?
You one of the best comics in the world.
The shore. It's like, it's so
many times people come up to me,
Rogan was talking about you like I
don't even have to be on the show.
Like they were like
Rogan's talking about you.
It's so like people will come up to come
to a show because you just spoke about
me. But it's true.
You and I had been friends for 20 what?
28 years or some shit. Something
crazy. So long fucking time.
But you've always been one of the
best comics in the world, you know?
And I think right now your new
Shit, man, that you're doing this.
Not even the special. I was crying
this weekend in Vegas, that new thing.
I want to say what it is, but God
damn, it's good. It's really good man.
I love that. You know,
I love the transition between when someone
does a special to writing and working
on new stuff because then you just get
this new angles and and having to write
shit. That's like,
I've been trying to tell this to Bobby
Lee who was another guy that is one of
the best comics in the world and it's
fucking shame that Bobby Lee doesn't have
a special and he doesn't, you know, it's
like he's thing is like, well no, no,
I won't be able to use that
in my mat material. Like yeah,
but you'll write better stuff.
Yeah. You'd be forced to. I think
he shooting a special though. Yes,
he's talking about it. Yeah. Cause
he's, he asked me who directed mine,
so I was like, oh wait a minute,
is Bobby about to shoot a special?
But he'll see how what you've seen and
what I'm seeing now that how great it is
to like come up with a new set of
material with all their fillings.
It's very terrifying. Yeah. I've had
some, uh, some amazing medio cassettes.
Jesus. I feel bad. I love when
you first tried out new stuff.
It's like you don't know.
Yeah. You just don't know.
And then you said something the
other day when we was in Vegas,
he was talking to Allie like we was all
in the back after the show about how you
had a joke that was new. It was working.
You wrote it, it's new, it's working.
And then you broke it
by over fixing it. Yeah.
Then you have to take shit back out.
And that's happened to me during
this new set of material too.
I started a joke, created it,
and then broke it by
over doing stuff to it.
And then I have to like figure out what
part that I put in there that threw it
off and take it out and fix it back. Well,
it's always interesting to talk to someone
that's really just a few years in a
comedy because then you got to go over
your own process and think about it more.
Yeah. The one of the things
that happens in Jujitsu is
in Jujitsu you get better when
you teach. It's a real strange,
like a lot of guys that wind up
getting a job teaching Jujitsu to like
beginners, they're Jujitsu jumps,
the jumps up several notches.
It's really interesting and I think
sometimes that happens with comedy.
So when we're dealing with selling
like Allie out to Allie Makowski,
our friend Alex, she's only been
doing comedy for what, four years?
Around somewhere around four or five
years and she's just coming into her own
and she's, what was she, 22.
All right. 22 or 23. 22 or 23.
Very funny. Very promising.
And uh, she, he was
going to come down and watch us because
she came to San Diego to watch when Tony
and Andrew and I did that, uh, that
giant arena down there because she's,
because she opens up for me all the time
at the Improv. And the comedy store.
She's getting to be around all these
assassins and she's getting to see it from
the outside. But that was her
first time opening and I was like,
it's cause she said she was going
to come down and watch. I said,
you want to do a set? And she was like,
I was secretly hoping you would ask.
I said all right, come on, can
we do this up? So she opened,
she did 10 minutes in front of,
you know, it's like 1200 people.
It's a lot of people for her first
big show in Vegas on a Friday night.
And she murdered and she did good.
She did great. Yeah, super relaxed.
But when you talking to someone who's
a up and coming like that, I love that.
I love, I love talking to like,
Hey Suze, hey Suze trio or like a,
you know,
a Frank Castillo or any of these young
guys coming up because you get a chance
to talk to them about how you
formulate stuff and compare notes.
And sometimes they have interesting
ways that they deal with,
cause I never considered, you know,
and sometimes people have interesting
ways of thinking about their mentality to
think about and when they go
walk their dog, they'll play,
they're set in their ear or they'll,
you know, when they go on hikes,
they'll just go on a hike and think about
one joke and try to work the joke out
while they're hiking.
You could have done that. Yeah.
I've learned a lot from by
talking to younger comics too,
so I get that completely.
You also,
the thing that's happening to you right
now is a thing that happens to them
except the fact that you're
far more skilled at it is
like they're trying to put
together an act. But you've
already done it many, many times.
You've already put out specials and
records so that when you're doing this,
it's like you know how to write jokes.
You're always writing new jokes.
You've been doing comedy
forever, but it's still,
you're starting from jump when you
start from zero, from ground zero like,
and then you try to put together an act
that you hope people want to pay to see
that as a dare.
Yeah, it's terrifying. Yeah.
And then there was a part of it in this
new set of material that I was doing
wrong. Like, like just this
style of joke that I was writing.
I just felt off like even when some of
the bits were working and then I was in
Atlanta a few weeks ago and then it
just hit me what I was doing wrong.
I was the laughing skull. Yeah.
I was the one laughing. So yeah,
it's a dope ass club to help little room
and it's a great room to go headline.
And when you're like got new material
that you'd need to just work out.
Yeah. I say about those rooms like the
belly room and like the laughing's call,
like that's where you find out
what's bullshit. Yeah. And I,
and I found out what was
pool of Shit for sure.
Sometimes you can like song and dance
your way through the 300 seat room.
Check them like enough people start
laughing to get the other people laughing
but,
and then you'll kind of go along with it
and with your delivery and you can kind
of make funny out of it, but there's
no momentum with 70 people. Yeah.
You have to like really make them
laugh. It's gotta be real. Yeah.
Was 70 people you got, you know,
I did a Jeremiah walk-in show,
stand up on the spot on Tuesday.
That's the best example of that because
you're also there yelling out subjects,
you know,
and so you just get to and you find
out and find and but that also like
constructing a new set.
What's interesting about it is that you
get a chance to figure something out and
make it real.
What like Bobby Lee's doing right now
is working with tried and true material.
Tried and proven. He kills every
night. He knows it's going to kill.
If it didn't kill, he'd be stunned. Right.
He'd be like, what? This is my shit.
I've been killing with this for four
years. He knows what he's doing.
He's just a funny machine.
So like, I don't even know how
to describe it just is just him.
He's just a funny ass fucking, yeah.
So funny. And people don't,
not enough people know.
Cause most people know them from
podcasts and that helps for sure.
And from television shows
that helps for sure.
But that needs to be something people
could see of his stand up. Yeah. So we're,
we're getting them, he's listening.
It's like he's a slow, but he'll listen.
Take a little time. He listens. It's
getting in there. It's getting in there.
It's too good. It's still good. The
other ones, Owen Smith. Yeah. Yes. Oh,
and Smith good to good. Has
his own style. Fucking funny.
He's a, yeah man. He's a
top flight headliner. Yeah.
Like a good headliner. Like a top
of the food chain headlines. Yeah.
Like if someone told me Owen Smith was
selling out arenas, I'd be like, good.
It should have been happened in
a long time. Exactly. You know,
and as much as Kevin Hart or
fucking fill in the blank,
whoever can sell out giant ass places
and Smith's material is as good as it.
The songs in those places. A
hundred percent hundred percent.
And sometimes these
guys, they just don't do,
they don't do enough a road
work or they don't do enough.
They'd got writing jobs or something
takes them off the path where people don't
necessarily see, they do a lot of
acting. It's all different little paths.
It kind of deviate you away from, from
stand up. Right. And I think I went back,
went down that path when I was on fear
factor. Oh yeah. It was on fear factor.
I didn't really tour much, you know,
it was mostly just being around la cause
it was, we're filming so much film,
so many episodes. And you guys traveled
a lot to different places. Yeah. Yeah.
That shit is exhausting,
man. Exhausting. Yeah.
And it was exhausting too
because you'd be filming all day,
you'd be out in the heat and then
you would come back and you know,
after that I would do standup
at night and I was just like,
I'm just going to just do
the store and then go home.
I wasn't going to travel anywhere
I a little bit, but not much.
So it's like things can be good where
it's like it's great to have a good Gig,
but things,
those things can be bad
cause it ultimately takes
you away from your standup.
You know what I mean? Lucy
Kay said that to me once.
He was in the period after he stopped
doing his show and he just stopped doing
it for awhile and I said,
I haven't done anything other than
stand up for a year. And I said, well,
wouldn't, what made you do that? He goes,
I just wanted to really
concentrate on standup. He said,
I don't think you could be at your best
while you do other things. He goes,
I think you could be good,
but I think at your best you really have
to just do standup. I think he's right.
Oh he's right.
Even if you don't do much in that day
and if you just write one line or one tag
or something as just,
it just counts so much towards the whole
thing and by the end of the year where
you, where you end up is going to be
way further than you would have been.
I think it's not an even formula though,
because I do think that there's some
value in taking some time and doing things
as well. There's like there's
value in like vacations,
there's value in experiences and then
there's also you have to do a lot of stand
up. This is like both things are
true because if you only do stand up,
one of the things that does happen is
guys lose their point of references
because their whole life
revolves around traveling.
So you get a lot of airplane jokes
and it revolves around drinking.
Cause people drink at clubs. You
don't have enough experiences.
You gotta live a little yes, yes. To
put it on the paper. Yeah. On stage.
You gotta live a little. I think that's
a, that's something that gets missed,
but it's like, it's not a perfect formula.
It's also like how much enthusiasm do
you have? Like sometimes more enthusiasm,
like when you have,
you feel good about it when you take
time off and it makes you better. Right.
It's just hard to know. It's just like
an athlete. Like, like in England,
the soccer season is over, right? So
the soccer players go on vacation,
but while they're on vacation,
you gotta get in a month or so.
You've got to get back to
training in a month or so.
But you can't go back
to camp out of shape.
So there's a point where you have to
be with a trainer while you're kind of
offered a season getting in shape
so that when you go to camp,
your not out of shape and you
losing your spot on it. Is this,
this or this is a delicate
balance of everything. Yeah,
that makes sense. And also so
insanely competitive, right?
There's so many people lined up,
but you take your spot. Yeah,
you can't get fat when you're on vacation.
So it's comedies like when you, uh,
shoot a special and then the guy that
couldn't follow you is killing because he
still has his material that he's been
had and you're like not doing as good
because you're working
on shit. It kind of,
it kind of fucks with me a little
bit. Yeah. You know what I mean?
Just to competitiveness offshore.
And then I said, hey man,
this is just a natural order. Things
just keep doing what you're doing and,
and everything is going to be
fine. You would figure it out.
You're growing again. There's
nothing wrong with that.
Whenever new bits come to life and
they start to really work, I go, okay,
this just trusting the process. This
is what happens. You trust the process,
keep grinding, but you have to
do that. If there is no, if,
if you don't put in that time, if you
just decide, oh, I need a new act,
but you don't work on it, it's not going
to just show up. Uh, seems you have to,
you have to make that process
is a real thing. Right.
And there's going to be
subsets. Just a care man
for sure. Like, yeah, like yeah,
you take one old joke on stage
and there's butter it add to it.
Yeah,
but one thing is true for sure for me
who sent when someone like you is writing
new stuff and that new stuff
kills like this past weekend.
That makes me excited about
writing new shit. I go, oh my God,
there it's out there. I've got to
find it. I got to find the bits.
They're out there. Look, he just
found two giant juicy giant drinks.
It's like someone come back from a
fishing trip. Oh good. The guys that tuna,
I'm calling toner Fisher. It's
out there. It's out there.
There's gold in San Francisco.
Yeah, let's go dig it.
It's cold in them there hills. But I
always see you go find new material,
so it's always good. Like,
like we both had new shit this weekend
and we're enthusiastic about it and
excited about it.
So it adds a different level to just
going out to do a show that we would
normally do.
We get to talk about it afterwards with
the excitement of how new the material
is and how it's coming
along and it just, that's,
that's a level of fun right there.
You don't experience unless you're,
you're out there writing and growing.
Yeah. There's no other way around it.
And I think a metaphor
for life.
I think the people that get stagnant in
life things cause you're not taking any
chances. You're not doing anything new.
You're not growing. Yeah. You've got to,
I mean, and artistically with stand up,
it's one of the rare art forms
where you cannot do the old stuff.
They don't want, I mean, maybe if Jim
Gaffigan people want to hear hot pockets,
but they also want to
hear an hour, a new shit.
You maybe if you're Bert Kreischer,
they want to hear the machine story.
He says they get mad if you don't.
He doesn't tell the machines,
tells the machine store,
take his shirt off. They,
he's mad at his clothes when he starts
taking his pants off and then just puts
him back on. I'm like, Hey, fucking
pants off while you pants on, bro.
How dare you. It's free. That'd
be his new shirt, party and pants.
Free Party with no pants or partying
pants. Free Party and pants. Pants.
Yeah, Bert Kreischer. There you go.
That's maybe a new special party
and pants free. Just you fas.
Fuck with boxer shorts. They're
talking shit about sober October wise.
It'd be way better tidy white. Go
all in. Yeah, but boxer shorts,
when he moves funny, his dick hole will
open up a little bit and get a peer.
Mr Speedos. Well, how about just speedos?
How about Bert onstage of speedos on
speedos? Don't seem like a comfort move.
Seems like a bad decision.
That's not someone who really wants
their Dick to be caressed and cradled
details are like you're punishing
your deck. Fucking took your,
it's like a tent in a storm and nail it
down. Punishing it or showing it off,
right? Yeah. If you got to hog.
Yeah. Penis enlargement by speedos.
Yeah, just put a,
just take your circumcised Dick and
pull it all the way down so it's a full
erection. Hey Man. And then put a ring,
a rubber ring around the base of the
balls to contract all the blood or
constrict all the blood. Yeah.
That's a weird thing that someone figured
that out, right? Cock rings. Yeah.
Hmm. How do I, uh, how
do I stay hard here?
It's gotta be a way to put a rubber
band. The praise your Dick. Try our grow.
Yeah. Yikes. Yeah.
That's the one thing that
if they do ever come up, I,
I used to have a bit about that.
If they ever come up with a pill for how
to look a boner or a a dick enlargement
pill, that actually works.
It'd be 30 seconds later.
The first dude would die of an
overdose. Oh yeah. Just take one.
You're going to find out how many,
give me a stroke. How Big One.
The one that Jesus
Christ, y'all had a hole.
There was a whole sequence where women
would evolve because people just don't
have sex,
but the dicks would get bigger and then
Ryan would develop these flying Squirrel
pussies.
They would just jump off cliffs to get
away from dudes who were chasing after
them with their big dicks and
shopping carts, Solaris grow wings.
Why are women growing wings?
Just to fit so people could make,
yeah. Yeah. If you could grow a big, like,
have you ever watched a porn and said,
that's just too much. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like this comes a certain point in
time where like how big do you want your
arms, right? Yes.
You want a big arm or do you want an
arm where the bicep touches your fingers
when you go like this? Right. Do you
want that? Oh, you can't even move. Yeah.
That's crazy. It's too big. Yeah.
Right. Does that mean send me,
you can never do this. You just
do anything like this now. Yeah.
You probably can't even walk.
Yeah. You're just too heavy.
You probably waddling everywhere you go.
You weigh 600 pounds and you're five,
eight. How the fuck are you doing that
right? There is a, there's too much.
You can get too much. Yeah,
you can get too much dick,
but I bet it's like you get too
much. Those girls who get, uh,
body dysmorphia with their
breast size. Some girls go crazy,
like they have triple e's and they need
them an f, they get nuts. It's crazy.
They don't see it like
the way you're saying it.
That's how it happens with
anorexics bodybuilders. Yeah.
And this God Damn Bananas.
It is the Dick things to
weird one. Right. Yeah.
That will definitely,
it's definitely gonna happen since women
overdo it with their breast size and
like you say, they can't see
how weird it looks. Yeah.
It's a normal thing with humans.
If you've seen those guys that inject
their muscles with oil and it makes their
muscles swell up like balloons, it looks
so fake, but they don't see it there.
It's body dysmorphia. Yeah.
The thing that an anorexic gets when
they don't recognize that they're there
look like a skeleton.
When was at the airport in Vegas
and waiting for your pool thing.
There was this chick and she had like a
weird but poor girl and it wasn't real
and you could tell only she didn't
know that it didn't look real.
She probably thought it
looked amazing. Right? Yeah.
She's walking around with like
button every confidence that yeah,
people get strange because the butt thing
is treated differently than the boob
thing. Like a woman with really
large fake breasts is still hot.
Yes. But a woman with really large
fake butts like come on. Yeah.
That's comes off crazier.
Yeah. And Fake Lips.
So another one. That's crazy
too. Yeah, and we have rules.
It's weird. Yeah. Fake Lips. It's like,
what am I supposed to do?
Just pretend this is not happening in
front of me right now. Well it's also,
it fucks with your, apparently we have an,
when we see a certain person when
see people's faces, we have a,
an expectation where things are going
to be based on where things are. Right.
It's all like the Fibonacci
sequence, like the golden ratio,
the way your face is designed
like, like Ari Shaffir.
If RSU figure had a tiny nose, you'd
be like, what is wrong with your face?
Your face is big nose.
This is like how your style of face is
supposed to come with that style or no.
If it doesn't, it's weird. But then you
look at a guy like Greg Fitzsimmons,
his little nose, you know, if he
had Ari's nose, you'd be like,
what is that nose doing on your face?
It's crazy. It's like you fuck with that.
When you do something to make something
bigger or wider or you know
with, with your face, you know,
people get tattoos and different things.
I suppose people start in
large in areas of their face.
You just like getting
big ears, big of noses.
Who would have big ears come into
frame Dumbo ears thing. Well,
how about those holes
where people stretch,
they do those ages and they pull their
fucking ear hole out. The put the,
that earring hole at the bottom.
Make it giant like a hoop that's bananas.
Like what are you doing
to your ears? Yeah.
Like I don't want to fuck up the chance
of me not be able to hear some shit.
I don't think he does.
I don't think it's just,
I'm not doing anything personally
close to anything that I need.
I need this for what I need this for.
I'm not going to do anything to it.
That might jeopardize it in any way.
I always feel like that
about cauliflower here too.
They go to all the years
that I did Jujitsu,
I don't have cauliflower here because
I always wore ear guards, right?
It's like if you fuck with
the shape of your ear,
it fucks with the way sound goes in there.
Like take your ear and then talk, go
blah, blah, blah. Now put your tip,
the tips of your fingers on the top of
your ear and then fold them down. La, la,
la, la, la, la, la. It changes
the way sounds changes.
Sound like this helps sound. These
are speakers. These are bows, right?
You know what I'm saying? Yeah. You
fucking with your boat, your bows,
it's the shape.
Nature figured out a shape to collect
all that sound and get it inside your ear
holes, but when you're outside
of your ears like a rock,
like a lot of these wrestlers
or Jujitsu guys, they have,
it's all calcified so that
with that cauliflower ear on,
if you ever touched a call for a year,
it's like a rock under the surface.
Calcium rock. That's what it's
like because the, it's what it is.
It's the break in the skin.
It swells up because it bleeds and then
that blood calcifies and hardens and the
only way to fix my friend
Brett had his fixed, um, Brent,
um, Brent, my friend Brent had affected,
they had a cut his ear like a fish.
They had a full plant and then they had
to open it up and scrape out all the
hard tissue and then
sew it back up together.
And he couldn't do Jujitsu forever
because if he did Jujitsu again after the
operation, it would break open and
start bleeding again. Pam? Yeah.
I was looking for a picture
where a guy gets this part.
I've seen people with a plug in a
hole on the inner part here. Oh,
I've seen that. Yeah. But this
guy took it to a whole spot home,
knows he'd sit, oh my God,
that definitely had flux with
his hearing. 100% oh yeah, 100%.
He's got a giant gage hole in the bottom
and a medium gauge hole in the top.
And then big ones on his
nostrils where his nostrils,
he has like the bottom hole
where his nostrils are.
And then the above the nostros get
to holes. We can see the Septum,
the opened up the side of his nostril,
quarter size hole easily. Right.
I can't say that dude's real
happy. I just don't see it.
I don't understand that look. But Hey,
hey man, what are you going to do?
Ian Edwards will be with me
with Dave Chappelle Coma,
Washington and then Salt Lake
City Salt Lake City the next day,
which is August 3rd tickets
just went on sale. Um,
I don't think so. I think
they're on sale on Friday. Yeah,
but they went on presale.
The Way Dave does it,
you have to register as a
legit fan, like a human being.
They have to make sure that
you're not a ticket agency.
This scalp on these tickets and buying
them up in mass and then selling them
back. So Ian Edwards, it would have to be,
you have to show your
driver's license or something.
I don't know how they verify it,
but, and then once you register,
then you could buy the tickets and
it's for those people for a while.
And then after that,
then it's opened up to the general
public or the thing on Saturday.
Something like that. But a,
Ian's going to be with me.
Don L I don't know Rollins. Yeah. I
don't know if that's been announced,
but I just announced it. Donald
Rollins going to be there too.
I'm fucking pumped. We're going to
have some fast going to be crazy.
That was going to be wild. That's
going to be fucking crazy, bro.
This weekend was crazy. That weekend
is going to be fucking great.
Tacoma sold out in a day. 20,000
people. It's going to be nuts. No sleep.
I'm not expecting any sleep. No,
we're going to have some fun.
It's going to be crazy. All right,
so, uh, tell people you're special.
It's this weekend, a Friday, this Friday,
July 12th on comedy central at
midnight. Check it out. Ian Talks.
Bill bird percents. Ian Talk and if it
wants it a all things comedy did it,
right. Yeah. All things
calm. And then once it's out,
we'll be able to be streamed on
comedy central's streaming service.
Download the app, or just go to comedy
central.com you're able to see it.
They're beautiful. Yeah. Powerful ENL
headboard. Thanks brother. Thank you,
my friend. Much love. I love. Bye. Bye.
Okay.
Yeah.